Tim Ferriss: So sleep and sex. Let's dive
into this wide and exciting topic. Where
should we begin in a discussion of sleep and sex?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Maybe we could
start with how sleep impacts sex, and
begin with actually the literal
idea of separating those bedfellows,
and to the question of, should you have a sleep
divorce as a couple to prevent a real one?
Tim Ferriss: And sleep divorce
is sleeping separately?
Dr. Matthew Walker: That's right. Yeah. So a
sleep divorce is where you will sleep either
in separate locations or at least in separate
beds. The diluted version of the sleep divorce,
rather than sleeping in separate rooms and
separate beds is called the Scandinavian method,
which you think — it sounds so much
more salacious than it actually is,
which is, essentially, you've just got two
separate beds that you put side by side,
and that's the diet version of a sleep
divorce. But I do think that sleep divorce
idea is important because it is a taboo, and
it also can markedly improve things for people.
So when we've looked at survey data, both in
the US and also in the UK with The Sleep Council
there, what you find is that about one out of
every four couples who are surveyed will tell
you that they have had a sleep divorce,
that they will sleep in separate beds.
And we think that that may be in part
an underestimate because of the stigma
associated with it. And if you survey people
anonymously, you get to a number of — almost
one out of every three people will admit to
waking up at least in different locations.
And there is pretty good evidence from the
science as to why that number may make sense,
why 25 percent of all couples suggest
that — when we study couples who are
sleeping together objectively on almost every
measure that we can quantify about sleep,
sleep is worse when you are sleeping as a couple
relative to when you are sleeping separately.
The twist in the tail there though is that when
you ask people about the satisfaction of sleep,
there is definitely some group of individuals
that say, "Look, I feel more satisfied with
my sleep when I'm sleeping with my partner
than when I'm sleeping separately," despite
the fact that objectively their sleep is worse.
So I'm not suggesting it's a one size fits all,
but I think the taboo comes from the idea
that, "Well, if you're not sleeping together,
then you are not sleeping together."
And the exact opposite is true.
Tim Ferriss: That's British for having
intercourse? Is that what that means?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Thank you very much, yeah.
We just get over this. It's my desperately
unfortunate Hugh Grant genes that has me
trying to navigate around the topic rather
than just saying it straight. So thank you,
Tim. Yes. If you're not sleeping together,
then you're not having sex,
you're not having intercourse.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Dr. Matthew Walker: But the — oh, come
on, Matthew. Hold it together. But it
turns out that the opposite is true, that when
you get a couple who are sleeping well, their
sex life actually improves. And it's probably for
three reasons that we've uncovered. The first is
hormones, the second is sensitivity, and the third
is libido. And I'll try to park my Hugh Grant and
get right into it. In terms of the hormones —
Tim Ferriss: Take off the gloves,
Matt, take off the gloves.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Come on.
It's time. I'm wondering what you mean by saying
take off the glove in terms of this conversation,
but let me just skip it. You see, you opened
the door, Tim, and I walked right into it.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, here we go. Here we
go. Or put on the gloves, if you prefer.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, I think probably
best — but we know each other quite well now,
so maybe — anyway, so in terms of the hormones.
Firstly, we know that testosterone, gosh, it takes
a pretty sharp nose dive in males, and in females
when you're not sleeping well. Males who, if we
put them on a diet of maybe four or five hours
of sleep, they drop their levels of testosterone
somewhere by about 10 years of aging.
So a lack of sleep will age a man by a
decade in terms of virility. It's also true
of estrogen in women. And so when those two
sex hormones are not in play, you get a
reduction in the quality of the sex life.
The second component, and this is data
that we've only really got in females,
less so in males. But the sensitivity of female
genitalia increases when sleep is in high volume
versus when people are not getting sufficient
sleep. And we think that's due to the estrogen,
that when estrogen is in normative amounts because
you're sleeping well, there is greater vaginal
lubrication, which therefore leads to greater
sensitivity and greater pleasure by way of sex.
And then the final aspect is libido. We've
also found that when a woman obtains an
extra one hour of sleep, there is a 14 percent
increase in her desirability to be intimate,
to have sex with her partner. And I find that
interesting because if you put it in context,
the FDA-approved drugs for increased libido in
women, things like, I think it's called Vyleesi,
it's one of them I know. That will
increase libido in women by about 24
percent. But here is the simple addition
of one hour of extra sleep, you can get
more than 50 percent of that benefit drug free.
Tim Ferriss: Question for you, Matt. How are these
drug companies measuring increases in libido? Is
it a self-reported one-to-10 scale or something
like that, which can be very sort of fungible?
Dr. Matthew Walker: It is self-reported. So
many of those scales are subject. It's very
much like pain. When it comes to libido, it's
somewhat difficult to quantify. And of course,
it's not just about innate biological libido,
the conditions have to be right. You have
to have the relationship with your partner.
Which actually also reminds me, by the way,
when couples are not sleeping well — and this
is a study from UC Berkeley, not from my lab. But
what they found is that they have more fights,
they don't resolve conflict nearly as well
between them when they're having a fight. And
the reason is because you lose empathy. When
you are not sleeping well, your ability to
empathize with other individuals, and we now have
demonstrated why in terms of the brain networks.
You decrease that capacity for understanding
the other. And no wonder you're fighting,
and you're fighting in a pretty poor way.
Tim Ferriss: What's the playbook?
What's the best practices?
Dr. Matthew Walker: I'm not
suggesting that a sleep divorce is for everyone
by any means whatsoever. There are some people
for whom they adore sleeping with their partner
for lots of reasons, safety, security, intimacy.
But I think if you are interested in it, take
a graded approach. And I would suggest firstly,
just having an open, gentle conversation, and
don't be defensive about it. The second is,
don't suggest that it's permanent. Offer
the idea that, "Look, could we do this,
darling? Could we do this for the next
week or the next two weeks? And I'm
not suggesting it's forever. Let's just
see, and let's just try it on for size."
Then I think what people misunderstand about
sleeping together in the same bed is what they
miss. They don't really miss the majority of time,
because for the majority of time you're asleep,
you're unconscious. What you really miss are the
bookends of sleep. That sort of getting into bed,
having a cuddle, saying "good night," and in the
morning, waking up and doing the same thing. So
if you have a sleep divorce, what you can also do
is build that in. So whoever goes to bed first,
the other person comes in, you have your time,
you sort of cuddle, do whatever you need to do.
And then you leave and repeat the same process in
the morning. You don't have to do that every day,
of course, it's not going to be practical. But
in that way, you sort of get the benefits of
sleeping together whilst still having a
sleep divorce, if that makes some sense.
So I would just say be honest with yourself.
Tim Ferriss: I feel like sleep divorce needs
a rebrand. Maybe furniture polyamory, since
you'd be on separate pieces of furniture.
Sounds really sort of risqué, taboo, kind of sexy.
Dr. Matthew Walker: I am so stealing that because
when you bring that up in a dinner conversation
and you finally admit it to your friends,
they all think, "Oh, no, they're on the rocks."
But furniture polyamory, all sorts of swings
from the ceiling and —
Tim Ferriss: Oh,
it sounds very exciting. Very exciting.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah. Yeah. Candle wax
on the nipples, let's go.
Tim Ferriss: They're
killing it, yeah.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Exactly. "Honey, we've
got to switch things up if they're doing that."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So a question that has always
been unanswered for me. I have some theories, but
why is it — and this is my assumption just based
on broad strokes, having had conversations
with many people about this and observed
this also online. It seems that men tend
to run hot and women tend to run cooler,
in the sense that men will often want the
temperature in the room to be lower, the sheets or
the bedding to be thinner. I mean, this is part of
the reason why I use devices like Eight Sleep's,
not the only thing out there. They do sponsor
the podcast, but I used them before that,
so that you can have zones of temperature. I don't
know if this is something you've looked into it,
is that mostly attributable to muscle mass
and thermogenesis? Is it hormonal? How do you
explain that if — do you have an explanation?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, it's muscle mass,
thermogenesis. It's also regarding — and
thermogenesis really comes onto metabolic rate,
and then it's also hormonal based on testosterone,
which is in part a thermogenic hormone in and of
itself. That temperature difference, we
can measure and we can see it. Actually,
studies were done before we were looking at
this, not related to sleep, but just related to
core body temperature. And they demonstrated that
there are some age dependencies to it though, that
once you get past about 50 or 60, the differences
between men and women start to collapse and they
start to become much more similar to each other
than they are different. Why is that? It could be
in part because of the reduction in testosterone.
That happens also because of the muscle mass
degradation that occurs in males as well. But
that evidence of males in general, running hot,
is well demonstrated, and it does bleed over into
the night and cause those often sleep problems.
That's some of the reason that some people
will get fussy about sleeping together. A
lot of it is about movement. Also snoring is
a big concern with desiring a sleep divorce,
or it's a motivating factor, I should say.
Tim Ferriss: So we've talked about one direction.
We've talked about how sleep affects sex. What
about the other direction? Is sex helpful,
deleterious to sleep quality? What
are the factors if someone's trying
to give themselves the optimal dose of sex
to improve sleep, if there is such a thing?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah. And one should never
state that that's the reason you say, "Darling,
could we just venture into the bedroom? Of
course. But it's because I've had really
rough sleep the past couple of nights.
Can you just like — please knock me out?"
Tim Ferriss: That's a crowd pleaser.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah. Isn't it just — there's
a real divorce rather than a sleep one. But
I think the evidence is actually favorable
that when we survey couples, what we find is
that sleep — although there's a caveat here.
Sex, as long as it's associated with orgasm —
and I'm not pointing to any one of the two sexes,
maybe males. But please keep this in mind
that sex, as long as it accomplishes orgasm,
is associated with about 70 percent increase in
reported sleep quality that following night, and
people do fall asleep faster as a consequence. And
we're learning about the mechanisms, but I would
say that it's probably quite depressing to hear
that news if you are, let's say you are single,
or you don't have a partner, or your partner is
away for a while. You don't have to worry too much
because it turns out that masturbation is
a reasonable stand in. And what we've also
discovered is that masturbation, again,
as long as it's associated with orgasm,
produces a 47 percent increase in your sleep
quality. And actually, it will decrease the speed
with which you fall asleep by about 50 percent.
And you'll hear this a lot, some people will say
they use it as a method when they're struggling
with sleep. They will actually masturbate to
try to help their sleep. So masturbation is not
as impactful as intercourse based on the data,
but it's a sizable benefit that rests in your
hands, I guess. But it's a nontrivial benefit.
It's a playful topic of course, and we joke, but I
do find it interesting regarding the biology. And
we've tried to scratch the surface here and dig
down. Firstly, what we found is that the benefit
of sex with orgasm on sleep is hormonally
related. But now, it seems to be that when
women engage in intercourse that results in
orgasm, there is an increase in a hormone
called oxytocin, which I'm sure many people
have heard of. Now to a lesser degree, that
there is also an increase in men. But firstly, we
know that oxytocin is a sleep-inducing molecule
and you can inject this into the brains of
different animals. We don't do animal work,
we do human work, but you can see that
sleep induction benefit. The benefit in
men seems to actually be about a different
chemical called vasopressin. And although
that story is just starting to emerge, it
seems to be those two hormones. Oxytocin
more so for females, vasopressin for males.
Tim Ferriss: So vasopressin, that's interesting
to me because vasopressin is, as I understand, an
antidiuretic hormone sometimes given to adolescent
bed wetters. Also, while what it's prescribed as
desmopressin, I suppose — this is maybe a topic
for another time, but seems to have an impact
on short-term memory, which is quite interesting
to me. But how does vasopressin help sleep? Maybe
it just keeps you asleep longer because you're
not inclined to get up and go to the bathroom. I
don't know. I mean that's one of the reasons why
it's prescribed as desmopressin as well,
Dr. Matthew Walker: It's possible,
but it seems to have a sleep inducing
mechanism and we don't truly understand why —
Tim Ferriss: Why?
Dr. Matthew Walker: — but we think
that it's perhaps working at two different levels
of the brain. One is directly at the level of
the brainstem itself, where you're starting
to shut down the wake promoting regions. I
think we discussed that in the previous episode.
Things like histamine or adrenaline, serotonin.
So one component is working at the level of the
brainstem. The second is working at a much smaller
structure, but more in the middle of the brain
called the hypothalamus, which is actually where
we have what's called the sleep wake switch. And
it's literally a flip flop device. And there is
some signaling direction of vasopressin on that
sleep switch within the hypothalamus itself too.
But right now, I think it's pretty unclear
as to exactly how those mechanisms unfold.
But I do find them interesting because if we're
looking for novel sleep aids, all joking aside,
then should we be thinking about combinations of
oxytocin and vasopressin as novel sleep-inducing
capacity. I think the second part of those two
chemicals however, is also the other side of
the coin, which is the nervous system itself.
That when you are engaged in the act of sex,
the fight or flight branch of the nervous system,
what's called the sympathetic nervous system,
which is not that at all. It's
very agitating and aggravating.
It actually should be called the three Fs
branch, now I think about it. Which is the fight,
the flight, and the fornication branch of the —
Tim Ferriss: Good save, good save, good save.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — of the nervous system.
Tim Ferriss: Your Hugh Grant honorary
degree has not been revoked. All right.
Dr. Matthew Walker: I was trying to come in there.
But what's interesting is that you cannot fall
asleep when your sympathetic nervous system is
switched on. And I'm sure you've had the
experience. I've had this too, where you
are that you are tired, you know that you are so
sleepy and fatigued, but maybe it's because you've
just done a big event on stage and you're just
so wired. And it's called the “wired but tired”
phenomenon where you are desperately wanting
sleep, but you can't. The reason is because
your sympathetic branch is still switched on.
But post coitally, what happens is that you
go back to the opposite side, which is the
parasympathetic, which is this quiescent,
calming branch of the nervous system, and that is
the royal road to better sleep. So it's almost as
though the orgasm removes the block of the
fight or flight branch of the nervous system
and pushes you into that relaxed autonomic state.
And so I think that's — how do we work that with
new sleep inducing novel medications too?
Tim Ferriss: So a few things come to mind
for me. Number one is, guys, this doesn't mean
you have free license to open your extremely
bright blue light emitting laptop and watch a
bunch of porn right before bed because that may
stem some of the benefits. So you're going to
have to use that imagination instead of God
knows what arms race you're watching on PornHub.
Second is, guys, buy a Hitachi Magic Wand. Get the
wireless edition. You'll thank me later. If you
are in heteronormative relationship, that's for
your lady friend, and she will thank you as well.
Dr. Matthew Walker: I'm so wet behind the ears,
I'm now — can we please link to it in the show
notes so that I at least can click on the thing?
Tim Ferriss: I'm just going to edit that
so that you just say, "I'm so wet." And
then I take out "behind the ears" and see what
people come back with. They'll be like, "Wow,
that Matt Walker's really taken a side road
we didn't expect." Oh, God, I'm sorry to —
Dr. Matthew Walker: "I knew that
maybe he and Tim were friends, but…"
Tim Ferriss: I know I'm taking this down.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah. Where's that
position in Austin for me at the university? I'm
quick to jump from UC Berkeley. Anyway — sorry.
Tim Ferriss: So let's talk about another, let's
say, aid, outside of the Hitachi Magic Wand and
speed wank before bed — which I know I'm violating
the roadmap that you and I discussed a bit,
so I'm hopping ahead a little bit. But let's talk
about it because it's on the mind. Melatonin. How
would you suggest people think about melatonin?
Dr. Matthew Walker: If you look out there in
terms of the silverback 500-pound gorilla of
the sleep supplement world, it is melatonin.
It commands a multi-billion dollar segment of
the market, which is utterly stunning to me.
Melatonin is not really going to be your sleep
friend for a number of reasons. I think people
don't understand what melatonin does. Melatonin
is a hormone, by the way. It's sometimes called
the hormone of darkness or the vampire hormone,
just because it comes out at night. Doesn't mean
that you start biting into people's necks. But it
simply that it signals nighttime to the brain. And
what that does is it regulates the timing of
your sleep, but it doesn't participate in the
generation of sleep itself. And so you could
think of melatonin like the starting official
at a 100-meter Olympic race. That melatonin brings
all of the races to the line and begins the race,
but it doesn't participate in the race itself.
That's a whole different set of chemicals.
So melatonin is potentially useful when
you're traveling between different time zones,
but once you're stable in a time zone,
that evidence is very clear when we look
across all of the studies and we gather them
together in the same statistical bucket — and
it's called a meta-analysis approach. What you
find is that melatonin will only increase the
speed with which you fall asleep by 3.9 minutes,
which is really not that different to placebo,
and it only increases your sleep
efficiency by just 2.2 percent,
which is really not fantastic as a sleep
aid. But it's understandable when you then
go back to what we were just describing
as the mechanism, why would it improve
the quality of your sleep if it's there to
help the timing rather than the generation
of sleep itself? Does that make some sense, Tim?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it does. It does. And I think
this is also a good place to talk about not
just the minimal upside, because I would say
there are people out there — and I've experienced
this when traveling internationally. If you take
a walloping dose, it can help put you down. So
I would imagine the efficiency and the effect
on reducing onset time is dose dependent on
some level. So you can brute force it. And
I have found it very helpful, say, going from
one side of the planet to the other. However —
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, and I would use it too
in those circumstances, that's the only time.
Tim Ferriss: But there are taxes that you may
pay. And it makes me think about — I don't want
to steal the mic here, but a conversation I had
with someone, actually very smart researcher,
probably 10 years ago. And he mentioned in passing
that he took eight milligrams or 10 milligrams of
melatonin every night. And I remember talking to
him and saying — I'm no scientist, but my guess
is that if you take something that is produced
in the body, or something that is very similar,
so you could have, say, luteinizing hormone
and hCG, very comparable. And if you start
exogenously, meaning from the outside in,
providing your body with X, it is going to
have a negative feedback loop and things are going
to start to happen. So it doesn't strike me just,
again, starting from those principles that taking
melatonin continuously eight milligrams a night
would over the long term be a good idea.
That was sort of my stance, and I'd love
to know what are the downside possibilities.
Dr. Matthew Walker: You are absolutely right
in your thinking. The body has a huge number of
feedback loops, and when you start exogenously,
meaning taking it from the outside and in the
body, you can play with those feedback loops where
you start to shut things down. And the concern
with melatonin, even at five milligrams, or even
three, and certainly at 10, what we would classify
that is as a supraphysiological dose. Meaning that
it's a dose of a concentration that is maybe 10
times anything that your body would naturally
release. So it is a whopping dose in that regard.
And by the way, you've got no idea whether it's
10 milligrams or not. There was a study that
looked at 30 different brands, and what they
found was that based on what it said on the bottle
versus what was actually inside of the capsules,
it ranged from, I think, it was about 83 percent
less to 478 percent more than what was stated on
the bottle. Because at least in the US,
it's not FDA-approved. And just recently,
maybe it was three, four weeks ago, there was a
report demonstrating that melatonin overdoses that
have been reported to the US Poison Control Center
have risen by 530 percent over the last 10 years.
And what's especially concerning is where that
bump is happening. It seems to be particularly in
pediatric populations too. So we need to —
Tim Ferriss: That bad?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, exactly. Keep that in
mind. But coming back to your question, that is
far too high of a dose, and the concern is about
shutting down the brain's feedback. That's one of
the taxes that you could pay. Some people have
pushed back on social media and the internet to
suggest — firstly, and I think they're right, that
melatonin overall in terms of its mortality risk
profile is quite low. It seems to be a somewhat
safe molecule in the sense of absolute death,
but that's obviously a very extreme threshold
for you to use. People then also cite a study
where they said if you dose for a high
concentration for a long period of time,
there was no change in the individual's
generation of melatonin itself. But if you
look at that study, it's actually a case study
in a blind individual, and they were dosed with
melatonin at high concentrations for, I think it
was about was 37 days. So yeah, about five weeks.
And sure enough, by the end of that, when
they withdrew the melatonin supplementation,
the individual went back to producing the same
amount of melatonin that they produced before.
So you could argue from that perspective, no
harm, no foul. The problem is that's not how
people use melatonin, that people are using it for
six months, 12 months, five years. And therefore
I don't think we've got any scientific data to
meaningfully tell the public that they should
not have these concerns, in my humble opinion
too. And the reason I say that — you can think
about something like testosterone supplementation
in males. You can use supplementation, and after
three or four months if you stop, testosterone
production from the testes themselves will
start again. But there is a concern that has
to be had between the physician and the male
who wants that prescription that if you continue
to take it long term, it may ultimately shut down
the production of testosterone. And when you stop
after long term use, six months, 12 months, you
don't go back to producing your own testosterone.
Is that true of melatonin? We don't know.
But the reason I also would caution people around
melatonin, and I don't mean to scaremonger. But
firstly, there's some really fascinating data
in juvenile male rats where when you give high
levels of melatonin, you get testicular
atrophy, you get testicular shrinkage. So
that is certainly a concern, especially now we're
seeing melatonin doses in pediatric populations.
That's a real big concern. We also know that high
doses of melatonin will block the ability of your
hippocampus to form new synapses. Hippocampus
is a memory related center, and therefore it
makes it more difficult to learn new information
because you can't form brain connections as well.
So please keep that in mind. I do think though
that there is — I said that melatonin as the
sleep timing hormone. There is one study that
I looked at where I think you could argue that
melatonin has a sleep generating benefit above
and beyond simply the timing of your sleep,
which is that when you give it in somewhat high
doses in rats, it's thermoregulatory and it causes
hypothermia. So not hypothermia to the degree of
life concern, but basically it reduces core body
temperature. And we know that you've got to drop
your core body temperature to get to sleep. So I
think melatonin, if it does have a sleep benefit,
could be acting through this root of temperature
and I think that's fascinating for me at least.
Tim Ferriss: Few follow-up questions. So the
study, you mentioned the case study with a blind
person where I thought that was going — and keep
in mind that I know just enough to be
dangerous and throw around words that
I probably shouldn't — but if melatonin is, in
sighted people, triggered in part by light signals
or light cues, if you have a blind person — and
again, I don't know what role I immediately think
of the superchiasmic nucleus, I think it is the —
Dr. Matthew Walker: Suprachiasmatic nucleus.
Tim Ferriss: I always fuck that up. God damn it.
Dr. Matthew Walker: So close.
Tim Ferriss: Nothing ventured, nothing gained. How
do you say it properly? I always screw that up.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Suprachiasmatic nucleus.
And it refers to the chiasma, which is a Latin
derivative term meaning crossing and it's where
your two optic nerves from your left and right eye
meet and then cross over and reverse to the back
of the brain. It's right at that fulcrum of the
cross, and it's just above it. Hence supra meaning
above, chiasma meaning the crossing and the
nucleus, obviously. So suprachiasmatic nucleus.
Tim Ferriss: Supra — also as in
supraphysiological. So I'll just call it the
SCN. So what my thinking was, well it's really
not apples to apples if you're comparing
a blind person to a sighted person,
and it may be that their production of melatonin
is less affected or maybe already handicapped to
begin with in such a way that their processing
of and recovery from melatonin administration is
just completely different from a sighted person.
I mean, that wouldn't be shocking to me at all.
Dr. Matthew Walker: It's a wonderful acumen.
That's exactly why we often will work with
melatonin with these patients. Now it depends on
the form of the nature of blindness. For example,
if it's blindness because, let's say that
you had damage to the back of the head and
you damage your visual cortex and the eye itself,
the retina is intact, the optic nerves are intact,
but it's the back of the brain where you've got
that blindness disruption. That can happen there.
That's not necessarily a concern because the light
signals are still at least coming down the optic
nerves and hitting the suprachiasmatic nucleus,
this 24-hour — and the suprachiasmatic nucleus,
by the way, is where your circadian rhythm sits.
It's the master clock, the master 24-hour clock
within the brain. You've got clocks all over
the body, but that's the one, it's kind of one
ring to rule them all. It's like The Lord of the
Rings. It's one clock to rule them all. That's the
SCN.And that still gets light in people who
have intact retina and intact optic nerves.
If you don't, however, you don't get the
light signal to your suprachiasmatic nucleus,
your brain gets confused about is it nighttime
outside or is it daytime? And therefore sleep is
very disrupted. They have actually what's called
a free running sleep system where they just run
around the clock in terms of the circadian
rhythm. It's not regulated and set to the
light dark cycle. Hence we use melatonin. But is
that how normative is that case study? Firstly,
it's one person. Secondly, it's in someone
who has a deficit that already alters
melatonin regulation. Again, I think it's a
fascinating study, but I'm not sure I put too
much weight in it right now.
Tim Ferriss: Too much weight
into a single case study.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, I
know. I'm trying to be kind, but so I would say —
Tim Ferriss: I mean, case studies are important,
which is not to denigrate it in any way, but it's
easy to overinterpret or overapply something like
that. Question then related to the — not to get
too scientific, but the shrinking balls phenomenon
observed in these juvenile rats. So I'm thinking
of another thing you mentioned, which is say
anabolic use or anabolic androgenic steroid use
might be getting the AAS use, exogenous use. So it
could be in the form of testosterone replacement
cream. It could be injectable testosterone ate or
whatever it might be. And if used for an extended
period of time — and it doesn't actually need to
be that long. I mean, there are certainly
anecdotal reports in case studies of people
who even after what someone might consider a
reasonably moderate cycle of say eight to 12
weeks, depending on the dosage, I know one person
personally who had severely impaired testosterone
production and libido for about nine months
after a very short cycle of what I would consider
moderate dosing of some of these androgens.
And the reason I bring that up is you have the
testis axis, which is the hypothalamic
pituitary gonadal axis, right?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Which is simply — and
I'm fumbling around here, but you'll see where
I'm going at this. So if you interfere upstream
or directly, you inhibit, as I understand, the
light cells from producing any number of things
and then you have this shrinking testicle
phenomenon. How does melatonin — what is
the plausible mechanism for that happening? Is
it disrupting sleep architecture in a similar
way that would be observed from too little sleep
and therefore you see a decrease in testosterone?
What is causing that testicle shrinkage?
Dr. Matthew Walker: No, the study or the studies
really showed that the effects were directly
there in the testes themselves. And it was —
Tim Ferriss: Nasty.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah,
that it was directly altering the androgenic
benefits that would normally happen during
development, during adolescent development. And
it was inhibiting that androgenic — and andro
obviously being the sex hormones
and genic being the promotion,
the genesis. So it was inhibiting the normal
development of the testes and therefore leading
to a failure to promote them in terms of
their size and development. I think they
even have now done disease where they were
showing that the seminal tubes themselves,
the tubes for semen were also impaired as a
consequence of high doses of melatonin as well. I
could have that wrong, but that's my recollection.
Tim Ferriss: In high doses, if we are looking
at — since rats aren't always little humans, but
when we say high dose, are we are the sort of
mgs per kgs, milligrams per kilogram comparable
to what a human would be consuming if they are
taking — let's assume the dosing is accurate on
the bottle just for the sake of simplicity — eight
milligrams, 10 milligrams? Or would it be a
human equivalent of someone who, say, being
160 pounds taking 160 milligrams of melatonin? Do
you have any idea what the comparable would be?
Dr. Matthew Walker: It's difficult to look
at those ratios if you try to match the paper
in part because of the way —
Tim Ferriss: Administration.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — the administration, and
because it's direct administration rather than
going through sort of hepatic clearance
and the stomach and all of that stuff.
So it's going to be tricky, I think,
to do the one-to-one transformation.
Certainly what we found with studies, if you
are looking for a melatonin sleep benefit,
there was one paper that demonstrated probably
the optimal doses somewhere between about
0.3 to 0.5 milligrams of melatonin. Now, if you go
onto the internet, it's going to be very difficult
for you to get something even as low as one
milligram. And here we're talking about maybe
half of that dose of concentration. Most — you're
lucky if you can find three milligrams. Most will
be five milligrams or 10 milligrams. That's the
whopping dose that we're we're talking about here.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Oh, man, what a mess. Humans,
man, we make such a mess. It's just
like, I remember when they're like,
carrots are good for this. Let's isolate
beta carotene and megadose that. Oops. Yeah,
sorry about that. It's just over and over again.
So if we could keep on the sort of unconventional,
let's just say tips/perspective
side of things if you don't mind,
I would love to talk about, and this is something
that I haven't discussed with you at any length,
the art of minimizing sleep time. And this
may tie into CBTI, which I really don't know
that much about. But I, like a lot of people I
think have made the error, although it doesn't
feel like an error of getting into bed,
and even if my sleep onset takes an hour,
hour and a half because maybe I have that tired
and wired feeling, which a lot of people do,
a lot of veterans, people with PTSD suffer from
this overly activated sympathetic nervous system,
which I do a lot, and I'll just stay in bed. Even
if it takes me three hours to get to sleep, I will
often just kind of sit there and try to meditate
my way into oblivion, which doesn't always work
very well. So what's the counter approach?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, so I think one of
the sort of conventional tips for sleep, you can
find all over the internet and idiots like me, you
can hear speaking about the five tips of better
sleep hygiene. And there's very good evidence
for why those are sensible things to put in place.
But what about the unconventional? And one of the
unconventional components is to limit your sleep
time. As you said, there is the principle — the
principle treatment for insomnia should not be
the first line defense of sleeping pills that
we discussed in the last episode. The current
recommendation is something called cognitive
behavioral therapy for insomnia, or CBTI. And as
you can tell by the term, it works on two things,
cognitive things, in other words, your thoughts
and your beliefs about sleep and then your
behaviors. What are you not doing that you should
do to help your sleep and what are you doing that
you shouldn't be doing and you should stop doing
to help your sleep? And that's the CBTI component.
Probably if you look across the studies and
CBTI has a number of different features in
this treatment, this therapy approach. But
one of the most potent tools in the box of the
CBTI therapist is what we call sleep restriction
therapy, which sounds paradoxical. I come or you
come to me and let's say I'm your sleep clinician,
and you say, "I am not sleeping well. I'm in bed
for about eight hours, but I think I only maybe
sleep for four, four and a half hours. I'm just
not getting enough sleep. Can you help me?"
And my response to you is, "Excellent. I've
got a great treatment for you. It's called sleep
restriction therapy." And you hear the kind of the
record scratch and you say, "Hang on a second, I
just told you I'm not getting enough sleep and you
are telling me we're going to restrict my sleep."
It's actually a poorly termed phrase. It should
really be called bedtime restriction therapy.
And it works in the following way that right now,
if you take that example, you are in bed for
eight hours and you're sleeping for four hours,
you have a miserable sleep efficiency. So you
have a sleep efficiency of 50 percent. Half
of the amount of time that you're in bed, you're
awake, half the time you're asleep. We want to see
that around about 85 or greater in terms of your
sleep efficiency. That's what we think is healthy.
And so rather than actually having
you stay in bed for any longer,
we do the opposite and we use the biology of
your brain and something called sleep pressure.
So from the moment that both you and I woke up,
we've been building up a chemical that we've
sort of discussed with regarding caffeine,
which was adenosine. And the more adenosine
builds up the sleepier and sleepier you feel,
and the longer that you are awake, the heavier
that weight of sleepiness will be weighing you
down. So just take the extreme of let's say you
pull an all-nighter or you're awake for 36 hours.
Imagine how tired you are at that point when you
get into bed that following night. It's almost as
though nothing's going to stop you. Earthquakes,
wildfires, you're just going to get into bed
and you're going to be knocked out. Why? Because
you've just got so much sleepiness built up,
so much adenosine that hasn't been removed.
So we do a diluted version of that in CBTI with
sleep restriction therapy where we say, okay,
you're going to bed — just for argument's sake at
midnight and you're waking up at 8:00. Now what I
want you to do is actually compress that window of
time and I want you to go to bed not at midnight,
but now push it — go to 2:00 a.m. or 2:30 a.m. or
let's say 3:00 a.m. but you still wake up at the
same time. So where we restrict your sleep
is not by having you wake up any earlier,
which is kind of miserable. And most
people, people feel it's easier to go
to bed later than wake up any earlier.
So we start there, we limit the amount
of time that you are in bed and we restrict
it down to maybe six hours or five hours,
and the next day you're going to feel miserable.
You've only been in bed for five hours.
But what happens is that as long as you
commit to it and it has to be committed
and you have to work with someone who's going
to motivate you, and it is hard, but it works.
And after the second night of being in bed for
five hours, you've been awake for longer. So now
you've been awake for 19 hours during the day
and you're only in bed assuming for five hours.
And that increase in your adenosine
because you're awake now for 19 hours
straight for one day, for a second day, for
a third day, it all starts to accumulate.
And then at one point, maybe, and it depends on
the patient, let's say about four or five days
after that, they get into bed at 2:30 a.m. or 3:00
a.m. and then the next thing that they remember
is their alarm going off at 8:00 a.m., and for
the first time ever, they have slept all the way
through from front to back. Now in that example,
I've restricted their bedtime by three hours
and they're now sleeping a solid five hours.
But remember that's better than where they were.
They were in bed for eight hours and they were
only sleeping for four hours. So I've added an
extra hour and they're in bed for less time.
And then gradually what we do is we start to
back that up. Once you're stable and your sleep
efficiency is 85, 90 percent, then we'll say,
okay, now go to bed at 2:00 a.m. and then
now let's go to bed at 1:30 a.m. and now
let's try 1:00 a.m. and gradually we back
it off. And essentially it's like hitting
the reset button on your Wi-Fi router. You are
retraining the sleep system. And in doing so,
you can start to get people's confidence renewed
because that's a big problem with insomnia.
Tim Ferriss: I was going to say it sounds
like more than anything — well, I shouldn't
say that. Who the hell am I? But it seems like
principle among the reasons that would work is
that you are resetting sleep-related anxiety.
Dr. Matthew Walker: A hundred percent. Because
when you are suffering from insomnia, and I've
had my bouts too, and I know that you've spoken
publicly about struggles before, you go into the
bedroom and the bed just looks like the enemy and
you have lost all confidence in your ability to
sleep. And at that point your sleep controls you.
But by way of CBTI and sleep restriction therapy,
you turn the tables. Now, you control your sleep,
not your sleep controlling you and you regain
confidence. That is a huge win. I can't tell you
how big that is for people with insomnia. It's
a terrible fear when they go into the bedroom.
They just convince themselves "It's not going
to be my night." So does that sort of help? I
know it's a long explanation.
Tim Ferriss: It does help.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah. And it's a little bit
like working out. If I go to the gym for an hour,
and for the most part I'm probably only working
out for maybe 40 or 30 minutes because I'm looking
my phone, I'm chatting to people checking social
media, whatever it is. And so you're only really
working out for 40 of those minutes. It's not
an efficient workout. But now my gym says,
"I'm sorry, we're limiting it to 30 minutes
every day. You got no more time than that."
After a couple of days, I don't have the choice.
I'm thinking I'm not getting my workouts in. So I
put my phone on silent, turn it off, and I just go
in there and I hit the gym hard and I work out for
30 minutes straight. My efficiency is improved.
Tim Ferriss: So let's segue and I'll let you
choose how you want to bridge things to lucid
dreaming, and we can do it in a few steps if
necessary. In part because when I reflect on
the periods of best sleep, let's just say past
adolescence or early adolescence, some of my best
periods of sleep — and I could unpack what I mean
by best — but easiest, lowest stress periods have
been when I have focused on inducing lucidity.
Because instead of dreading sleep, I
end up looking forward to sleep and
it turned everything on its head. Now
the downside is, we might get to this,
there's quite a bit of training
required and things need to be a
bit regimented in my experience. But how
would you like to move to lucid dreaming,
including a definition of lucid dreaming?
Dr. Matthew Walker: I think perhaps what we
could do is start with what basic dreaming
is and what it is perhaps psychologically,
neurologically from the level of the brain
because neurological is important when we try to
understand what lucid dream, what lucid dreaming
is and how it's different to standard dreaming.
And we can also touch on the functional
benefits of dreaming, but maybe we could
leave that aside. I think we spoke a little
bit about that before in the first episode.
But from a psychological level, dreaming, I
mean, it's pretty ridiculous when you think
about it because last night, you and I, when
we went to sleep and we started dreaming, we
became completely psychotic. And before you reject
that sort of diagnosis of my nighttime psychosis,
I'll give you five good reasons. When we dream,
we start to see things which are not there. So you
are hallucinating. You also believe things that
couldn't possibly be true, so you're delusional.
You get very confused about time and place
and sometimes also person as well. So you're
suffering from disorientation. You often have
these wildly pendulum-like almost fluctuations
in your emotions. And it's what psychiatrists
will call being affectively labile or emotionally
labile. And then how great you and I both woke up
this morning and we forgot most if not all of that
dream experience. So we're suffering from amnesia.
And if you were to experience any one of those
five things while you're awake, you probably
would be seeking some form of psychiatric
intervention. But for reasons that we're now
only starting to understand when it comes to
the functions of dreaming, it's a perfectly
normal biological and psychological process.
The biological process is utterly interesting.
We and others have done studies where we've been
putting people inside of brain scanners and we let
them go through the different stages of sleep and
we let them go into REM sleep. Now dreaming, if
you use a loose definition, which is the report
of any mental activity upon awakening. If you use
that loose definition, you dream in almost every
stage of sleep. But what most people think of
when you say dreaming are REM sleep dreams. Those
are the emotional, the narrative, the bizarre,
the strange. That's really the state from which
you dream. And when we look at that sleep stage
inside of the MRI scanner, firstly vast swaths
of the visual cortex start lighting up in your
brain. The motor regions of the brain erupt in
activity. Emotional centers of the brain become
active as well as memory centers of the brain.
And in fact, some parts of your brain are up to
30 percent more active when you're in dream sleep
than when you're awake, which is stunning to
me because we often think of sleep as just this
passive unconscious state. But metabolically
from the brain perspective, it's wild.
But the freakish part is what happens to another
region of your brain called the prefrontal cortex,
and particularly the left and the right
side, which sits just above your eyes.
And it's particularly a region called the dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex, left and right side
of the frontal lobe. That part of the brain,
normally when it's active, acts like the CEO of
the brain that makes high level sort of executive
top-down control decisions. And it allows you to
have not just rational decisions but volitional
decisions. In other words, you are choosing to
make that choice and you're choosing to do that
action. That's part of the prefrontal cortex job.
That part of the brain goes offline when we go
into REM sleep. Your dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex doesn't erupt with activity like many
of these other regions. It is suppressed in
its activity. And that I think is our current
explanation as to why your dreams are so visual,
so motoric, filled with past memories, also just
highly emotional. But they're utterly bizarre,
utterly erratic, and you have no volitional
control. The prison guards have left the
building and the prisoners are running amuck.
Your prefrontal cortex is down. And so that's
one of the fascinating parts of dream sleep
neurologically — as well as the body by the way.
I think we probably didn't discuss this
before, but when you go into dream sleep,
your brain paralyzes your body. You are completely
limp. So if I were to come into the bedroom and
just pick you up during REM sleep, you would
be like a ragdoll. All of your skeletal muscles
are inhibited. And people don't need to worry,
by the way. Your involuntary skeletal muscles
that control your respiration and your heart,
they're not affected, but all of your voluntary
muscles are because your brainstem, which is
where the REM and non-REM mechanisms play out.
Not only does it beam an activating signal up
into the dreaming brain, it sends one down the
spinal cord and it paralyzes what's called
the alpha motor neurons of the spinal cord
that control your voluntary skeletal muscles.
So you are locked into a physical incarceration
during REM sleep, during dream sleep, which by the
way explains something called REM sleep paralysis
upon awakening and adequately explains most
alien abductions. But we don't need to go there.
We can always move on to what's different about
dreaming when it comes to lucidity or just pause
there and go into anything that comes to mind.
Tim Ferriss: No, let's jump into lucid dreaming.
I'm ready. I'm done now. And I do want to
talk about tracking of time or perception
of time at some point. But I think we
can do that vis-à-vis lucid dreaming,
because I have some yes questions, so I'll
get there. But let's jump into lucid dreaming.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, lucid dreaming. It used
to be a complete charlatan science back in the
'60s and the '70s. To suggest that you could gain
control over a normally non-volitional process
only added insult to the idiotic nature of this
thing called sleep and dreaming by itself. And
now you're telling me, okay, we've got these
things called dreams, and also you claim to be
able to control them and do whatever you like
in them. Really? Show me some good science.
But now we have some exquisite science and it's
not even debated anymore. It's not a charlatan
science. And the first experiments actually
come back to our first topic, which was sleep
and sex. The first experiments used orgasm and
ejaculation as the test. So with a lucid dreamer,
when they are asleep, just like you and I, when
we're not lucid dreaming, they are paralyzed. So
they've got no good way to tell you, "Okay, I'm
now lucid," and they have no way to tell you what
I'm dreaming about and what's happening,
except that they do, which is their eyes.
Because one of the two muscle groups that is
spurred from the voluntary skeletal paralysis
of your muscles are the extraocular muscles that
move your eyes up and down and left. And that's
why by the way, you still have rapid eye movements
during REM sleep, because those muscles are not
inhibited. So we can now generate essentially a
language between me, the experimenter, and you,
the lucid dreamer, which is like an ocular Morse
code. And you can be telling me, using predefined
eye movement instructions, what's going on.
So at the moment you become lucid,
you've gone into dream sleep, and I can
see that in the next door sleep control
center. And then all of a sudden I see, based
on your eye movement traces that I'm measuring,
you do three deliberate flicks to the left.
And that's your signal to me that "Me,
the participant, I'm now lucid." Okay, great.
Now then you're going to do two big circular
movements to the right. And that's you saying, "In
my dream, I'm now clenching my right hand and then
moving your eyes circular to the left. That's me
moving my left hand." And so you can be telling
me every time that you're doing something
in your dream what it is that you're doing,
which is just — I mean, could you imagine?
Tim Ferriss: And then if you're like,
"If you like that trick, now watch me ejaculate!"
Dr. Matthew Walker: Well, that was exactly what
they did. So then they said, okay, you claim to
be able to — because when you control — lucid
dreaming, by the way, the definition, is just that
you are aware that you are dreaming as you are
dreaming. That's our basic scientific definition.
But what most people in the lay public think of
as lucid dreaming is not just that you know
that you're dreaming, you take control over
your dreams. And of course, if you can control
your dreams, one of the things that people enjoy
doing is having sex and having an orgasm.
Tim Ferriss: That's all they're going to do.
That's all they're going to do.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Orgy all — everywhere.
Dr. Matthew Walker: It was the
original dreamscape pornography. Forget
PornHub, you just had to lucid dream.
Tim Ferriss: It's a heavier lift, but yeah.
Dr. Matthew Walker: It is. But I could argue it's
well worth it. So we've got these experiments now
— and by the way, we've done imaging studies that
are less messy for the experimenter to — but I
should come explain that by the way. People would
then say, "Okay, I'm now starting to have sex and
I'm now just about to have an orgasm." And then
they would say, "I've just had my orgasm." And you
can go into the room and sure enough, with males
especially, you've got proof positive data that
what they said was real. And hence, you've just
scientifically proven lucid dreaming is great.
We've got much more sophisticated MRI scanning
methods now, and I won't bore you
with the studies, but it's very
clear that we know that lucid dreaming is real.
The next question then was how do people lucid
dream? What is the underlying neural mechanism?
And this comes back to the prefrontal cortex
and those dorsal lateral prefrontal parts of the
brain, which are the volitional control centers
which go offline. What we found is that activity,
both the electrical activity and also when you put
people in scanners, the imaging activity in
those regions, starts to ramp back up again,
as if when you become lucid, you regain your
rational logical control over the dream state. And
so the prefrontal cortex gives you that capacity
to take back what you lost, which is volition.
There was a study recently, however, that I
think did a pretty good job to say that may
not be the case, that some of those are results
are confounded by the method of the analysis and
the method of the recording. So I think it's — the
jury is still a little bit out, but even in that
study, they demonstrated that there's something
about their brainwaves that is radically different
at that fulcrum point where they shift from going
from non-lucid dreaming to lucid dreaming. It's
not a question of if, it's just how.
Tim Ferriss: What is the jury still
out on? I'm sorry, I missed that.
Dr. Matthew Walker: So the jury is
still out on this idea that the electrical
bursting brainwave activity is — it comes
back online over the prefrontal cortex.
And what they were finding is that it's
potentially an artifact of the eye movements
that start to happen. So the eye movements,
when you're moving those muscles, those
extraocular muscles, you move muscles
using electrical impulses. And those electrical
impulses that are coming from the eye will also
bleed up into the brain. And when you
get all of this frenetic eye movement,
it starts to masquerade as if it's the prefrontal
cortex which sits directly above them as getting
reengaged. And hence, when you control for that,
you don't see as powerful an argument for the
re-engagement of the prefrontal cortex.
Tim Ferriss: What is your personal
experience, if any, with lucid dreaming?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Unfortunately, I am not a
common lucid dreamer. It's happened probably
about two or three times in my life.
And when it's happened, it's immensely
pleasurable. Have I tried to curate it,
develop it, and use different techniques? And we
can speak about the current techniques that are
out there in the science. I have not chosen to
do that. And it's not necessarily because I see
in the science anything to be worried about.
I can steel man both sides of that argument.
We know that only about 10 to 20 percent of
the population are natural lucid dreamers.
And you could argue from an evolutionary
standpoint that if lucid dreaming is so adaptive,
so beneficial to us as Homo sapiens, then the
reverse would be true, that Mother Nature would've
heavily selected it, and 80 to 90 percent
of the population would be lucid dreamers.
But I can push back on my own argument because
there's a desperate flaw in that logic. That
argument assumes that we've stopped evolving. And
we haven't, right? So maybe that 10 to 20 percent
of natural lucid dreamers are the forefront of
hominid evolution and we don't need to be worried
about AI — we need to be worried about the lucid
dreamers becoming the next super race of humanity.
So I wrestle between those two, but if it's that
volume though, that 80 to 90 percent of people
don't naturally do it at this stage after 3.X
million years of evolution of hominid development.
My sense is that do I think that I understand
better than Mother Nature's blueprint exactly
what I should be serving up in my dreams at
night to get all of the benefits of dreams. And,
by the way, we know that dreaming, above and
beyond REM sleep itself, serves a number of
key different functions like emotional therapy
and emotional first aid. It supports creativity.
And I've worried myself, is it hubris for me
to think that I should then take the reins and
get into the driver's cockpit and start steering
the vehicle, rather than just allowing whatever
Mother Nature thinks should happen for me?
I don't know. The only other strike against
lucid dreaming, and I don't think it's a big one
and I don't think it's anything to be worried
about, when you survey people and when we've
examined people who claim to be lucid dreamers,
on a night after lucid dreaming, they
typically report that their sleep is less
restorative and less refreshing. They find
it to be, perhaps, more mentally fatiguing,
but I don't think that's really a big —
Tim Ferriss: The second night?
The subsequent night of sleep?
Dr. Matthew Walker: No, sorry. The
next morning when they wake up after —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I understand.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — the night when they have
had lucid dreaming they find that it was more
fatiguing, perhaps because it's more effortful
because you're engaging the prefrontal cortex.
That's one argument, but I don't think
that's a particularly good argument to
say that if you are a lucid dreamer you need
to be worried or if you want to lucid dream
you should not engage in some of the different
methods that we've developed to improve it.
Tim Ferriss: I'm curious what the state of the
art is from a scientific perspective, because
people may hear the term lucid dreaming and think
that it is a relativity new construct/exercise of
the human mind, but that's not true at all.
I mean, at least for thousands of years in
Tibetan practices and elsewhere —
Dr. Matthew Walker: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: — there have been elaborate
descriptions of training and philosophical
and cosmological implications of this type
of sleep engineering, let's call it. What
are the predominant methods of or for inducing
lucidity in these studies? Or that you've seen
covered in the literature? I'm very curious.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, right now in terms
of the science, we probably have two methods
that have been put out there that have some
degree of validity to them. Although, I would
say that when you look at each one of the papers,
the statistical robustness, in terms of
the reliability of these things, it's not
especially high. I mean, some of these techniques
do gain statistical significance, meaning that
when you try them, it does significantly, from a
statistical perspective, increase your likelihood
of lucid dreaming. The first one, it's called
the MILD method for short, but it stands for the
Mnemonic Induction of Lucid Dreaming, M-I-L-D
method. And, essentially, it's pretty simple
that you create a conscious and very deliberate
intention to remember that you're dreaming and
usually this is pre-bed, that you're lying there
before you go to sleep and you start repeating
this intention, "I am going to deliberately
remember that I am dreaming as I'm dreaming."
And you keep doing that, night after night,
over and over again, and it sounds hokey,
it sounds really quite science L-I-T-E,
lite. But the evidence is suggesting,
it's in favor. I think the other one that's
probably more popular is called the reality
testing method and, oh, gosh, it was popularized
in a — at least I think it was popularized —
Tim Ferriss: Stephen LaBerge?
Dr. Matthew Walker: No. Well, so Stephen
LaBerge was a fascinating researcher who was
working here in the Bay Area in the 1980s and
'90s who probably was really the pioneer of
modern day lucid dreaming. And then, at some
point, he was doing academic really interesting
scientific studies and then he moved away and he
developed his own Lucidity Institute and sort of
was selling CDs how to do that. So I think it went
off in a slightly strange direction, and I don't
know what came of him. But the reality testing
method actually came to fruition, on many people's
radars, with a brilliant movie called Waking Life
by Richard Linklater. Have you seen this?
Tim Ferriss: It's great. Yeah.
Dr. Matthew Walker: And maybe we can link to it
in the show notes. If people haven't watched it,
don't worry if you're not interested in lucid
dreaming, yes, the movie revolves around lucid
dreaming, but the philosophy and the conversations
will blow your mind. It is one my favorite —
Tim Ferriss: And the visual
treatment of the movie —
Dr. Matthew Walker: Oh, is so —
Tim Ferriss: — is perfect.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — clever. Isn't it genius?
And maybe we won't spoil it for people who
haven't seen it. But the idea of the reality
testing method is that during the waking day,
you start to test reality, in a way that you
don't normally do. So let's say that I would
walk over to the table that I'm sitting next to
here and I press my hand down on the table and the
table is resisting my hand, just like the waking
laws of physics would predict. Or I go over to
the wall and I switch on the light switch, do the
lights go on? And when I turn them off, do they go
off? And hence, I understand that I'm probably in
conscious waking reality. And you start doing this
throughout your entire waking day to the point
where it becomes a reflexive habit, and then the
hope is that that habit bleeds through into your
dreaming life from your waking life and you start
to do the same reality testing in dreams. And
then, all of a sudden I press my hand down on the
table and it moves all the way through the table
to the other side. And at that point I think,
"Oh, the jig is up. I'm not awake. I'm dreaming,"
and then you gain lucidity. Does that sort of —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — make some sense?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it does. Actually, if
you don't mind me just — because I don't
think I've discussed this at any real
length in any podcast, but this was a
very strong focus of mine for a part of the last
two years of high school. And then, I revisited it
a few years later in college, and one might ask,
"If you enjoy it so much, why the break?" And the
break is because there's training involved and I
do suggest, this is an oldie but goodie, I'm sure
there are, actually I know there are many, many,
many books that have been published since, but
Exploring the World of Lucid Dreaming by Stephen
LaBerge. B-E-R-G-E. I'm probably mispronouncing
the last name because I can't speak French. But
that book lays out the MILD technique that you
mentioned and the reality testing. And I love to
just give folks an idea, perhaps a few stories,
and these are, yes, anecdotal, and of one. But I
hope them to be, perhaps, inspiring in a sense.
So number one, I do not count myself among
the people who are natural lucid dreamers,
at all. I think most people have had
the experience of lucid dreaming. "Oh,
my god, I became conscious. I was dreaming and
then I immediately woke up or went back into
non-lucid dreaming." Most people have had that
experience, and I'd had that experience who knows,
much like you, two or three times scattered
over a very long period of time. But then,
I read Stephen's book and step one is practicing
dream recall and putting together a dream journal.
And there are a number of reasons for this, but
one of the reasons is to identify good candidates,
recurring patterns, that you can use as cues
for your reality testing in waking life.
So, for instance, if you identify and your
dream recall improves dramatically when you
begin to journal in this way, immediately upon
waking. You can't check your phone, you can't
brush your teeth, you need to just roll over and
immediately do this. And I do not think voice memo
works nearly as well, because you'll go back and
you'll reread the skeleton outline of fragments
and that will prompt further recollection and you
can fill in the blanks and that is a productive
way of approaching it. You might identify that
you walk through many doorways, for instance, or
for whatever reason you end up in areas
where you see grass or perhaps you look
at your watch often in dreams, at which point
you would identify those as candidates for this
reality testing that you were referring to.
Or you can simply have an alarm, after you've
started doing this dream recall, and at random
points in the day, you have to do a reality
test. Let's give a couple of recommendations
for folks. The first is if the reality test
is hard to precisely convincingly test, it may not
translate to dreams. So what I mean by that is,
a lot of folks, when they're starting this will
say, "Well, I will try to fly." And yes, you can
fly in dreams, and I wasn't kidding earlier when
I said that people just go complete nymphomaniac.
Generally, when people first gain the ability
to intermittently induce lucidity, they're just
fucking everything and they're flying everywhere.
Those are the two things that everybody does.
And that's fine. But if, during your waking
life, it's like you have lunch and then the
alarm goes off and you're like, "Let me
reality test." How are you really going
to attempt to fly in a convincing, compelling way?
But there are other options. For instance, and who
knows, science can be expensive and who knows if
these studies will ever get done or how they would
even be done? But what I think experienced lucid
dreamers will probably corroborate it that if you
look at a pattern, let's just say you have long
tiles that have one orientation in a restaurant
and you look away from them and look back
at them, in reality, they stay the same.
In a dream state, they very often, almost always
reorient, because your mind is reconstructing
that pattern, if that makes sense. And similarly,
if you look at, say, a digital clock read out,
something like that, the numbers will
not be the same, the time will change.
And just for the practical applications
here, yeah, you can have fun doing stuff,
but at the end of high school I was going to be
competing at a national-level in wrestling and
so I would actually train with this coach from
Oklahoma, John Smith, who'd I'd never met, still
haven't ever met, and I would actually do drilling
in lucid dreams and, again, and of one, who knows?
But I really seemed to discern a translation of
that added practice time to the in-world practice,
so to speak. So it's a fascinating experience,
I encourage everybody to try it out, but it is
a commitment. It's quite a commitment.
Dr. Matthew Walker: It is.
Tim Ferriss: It's kind of like if you want to
control your anger and you want to have a pattern
interrupt and you need to develop that over
time and to take something that is subconscious
and make it conscious does take some time.
Dr. Matthew Walker: And I think that it's
fascinating, that last part that you said where
when you were working with the coach that you
truly, actually never worked with, but you
saw it translate to the mat in the waking,
real world. I think it fits very well with
the idea of one of the functions of dreaming,
which is this notion of abstract creativity, of
problem solving. And we know that it's during
the dream state, it's during deep non-REM sleep
when we take individual memories that we've been
learning and we cement them and we essentially hit
the save button on them and we sort of concretize
them in the neural architecture of the brain. But
it's during dream sleep that we take those newly,
freshly minted memories and we start to
interconnect and associate them with this
vast catalog of previous knowledge that we
have, so that you start to divine solutions to
previously impenetrable problems, and the reason
that happens is not because the dreaming brain is
designed to build the obvious connections,
it seems to do a Google search gone wrong,
where it takes the new information, it inserts
it and it immediately puts you to page 20.
So maybe I type in "The Tim Ferriss Show" and
it takes me immediately to some field hockey
game in Utah. And I think, "Hang on a second,
how on Earth is that related?" But if I look,
there is a distant. non-obvious connection, and
this is what the dreaming brain and perhaps the
lucid dreaming brain is particularly good
at. It starts to fuse things together that
shouldn't normally go together, but when they do,
cause marked advances in evolutionary fitness and
it's the biological basis of creativity. And so,
I think what's happening with that description
that you mentioned, is that you're waking up
in terms of your skills, your motor skills,
but also happens with knowledge, with a revised
mind wide web of associations. It's almost like
informational alchemy that happens at night,
and that's why you can have these remarkable
stories of people solving problems and coming up
with incredible creative solutions and wonderful
pieces of art and music and literature have all
been inspired by way of dream creative insight.
And I think that's why, perhaps, in part why you
were feeling good about that benefit, is there are
certain ways that you were performing skills and
movements that you just couldn't see when you're
awake, but when you go into the dream state and
you force that to be on the menu of the dreaming
digestion at night, then all of a sudden the
dreaming brain was taking what you were learning
and coming up with these novel, new insights.
So I think it fits very well with what we know
about one of the functions of dreaming,
and it's the reason that you've probably
never been told to stay awake on a problem.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, and I have not experienced
the subsequent fatigue, which I think would've
be, at least for me, very obvious, because I was
training every day. And so, I think I would've
subjectively noticed a decrease in performance.
And I will just put a call out to the audience,
if anyone out there is aware of someone who is the
heir apparent or maybe the version two, version
three or not, but of Stephen LaBerge, but somebody
who is really taking lucid dreaming seriously,
the different techniques for induction, perhaps,
looking at the interplay of sleep, nutrition,
other variables on inducing lucidity, please let
me know on Twitter @tferriss. T-F-E-R-R-I-S-S,
because I am deeply interested in this. And I
remember back in the day when I was at school, I
mean, this was in the '90s, but some of Stephen's
acolytes were experimenting with things like —
actually I was experimenting with huperzine A, but
others were experimenting with galantamine and all
these various supplements in the hopes that they
would increase the frequency of inducing lucidity.
Dr. Matthew Walker: And there are some devices
out there right now where people
have sort of tried to have these
ocular devices where they start to sort of flash
lights into the eyes, and the reason that they
use the ocular device is that the device itself
can measure some parts of the brainwave activity,
it can measure the eye movements, it senses when
you go into dream sleep, and then it begins the
flashing and the hope is that that flashing is
an instigating trigger to build lucidity and
make you aware that you're dreaming. I've seen no
data on how effective those are scientifically.
But people are trying to take this to the next
level. People have played around with compounds,
they're now playing around with technology.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So I'm going to give
some further unsolicited thoughts that will, no
doubt, just be very bothersome, because they're
not based on any data to speak of, other than
my personal experience and also having read a
number of books and different reports and gone
on all these crazy forums, but experientially,
and this could be pure placebo effect, but for
most folks, when they realize they're dreaming
it's like, "Oh, my god, I'm dreaming," and
then they snap right out of it. Either they
wake up or they go right back into normal REM
sleep, let's just say. For whatever reason,
looking at your hands or spinning, attempting to
spin, like just spin in place much like you would
physically, seems to help extend the session of
lucidity, so to speak. Again, no studies to cite,
no hard data to point to, but for people who want
to screw around with it, there you go. It's free
advice, maybe worth what you pay for it.
I would love to, if we could go from here,
perhaps, to segue to learning and
memory and I know that you're very
deeply familiar with research as it relates
to sleep, different phases of sleep, and
various aspects of cognition, including
memory. If one wanted to optimize for learning,
now there are different types of learning,
right? You could have procedural knowledge,
like riding a bike of skill acquisition, like in
my case, the wrestling. You could have declarative
knowledge, more data-driven, memorizing Chinese
characters is one that I've thought about a lot.
How would you suggest people think about sleep
and are there ways to optimize for learning or
skill acquisition, aside from ensuring that your
sleep is just not broken in some fundamental way?
Dr. Matthew Walker: I think what we've started
to understand is that different stages of sleep
do different things for different systems of
memory at different times of night. So yes, the
story is simple that you need sleep for learning
and memory, but there is evidence that we can
pattern match what type of things that you're
learning with a particular stage of sleep,
if you wanted to try to dial it up. If we
were so replete as scientist to have dials
like a mixing deck where we could instantly say,
"Okay, tonight you want more stage two non-REM
sleep or you want more spindles, you want more
deep sleep." I mean, we're getting there with
brain stimulation, but it's not quite there yet.
Tim Ferriss: The Deadmau5 DJ of sleep cocktails.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Exactly. Yeah, yeah. Maybe
I should grab that Twitter handle already. But
certainly what we know from the bigger perspective
is that, firstly, you've got to get sleep before
learning to prepare your brain for the initial
act of imprinting and learning new information.
And we've done some studies where we've deprived
people of sleep and that night of deprivation,
should you pull the all-nighter? Is
it a wise idea? And the answer is no,
because you're about 20 to 40 percent deficient
in your learning ability when you have not been
getting sufficient sleep, which I do think is
interesting when you consider what's happening
to sleep in our education populations
right now, but I can put that aside.
We also know why that's the case. We did a study
where we were looking at the brain trying to learn
information with and without sleep inside an
MRI scanner and there's a structure that we've
spoken about before called the hippocampus, which
sits on the left and the right side of your brain
and it's almost like the inbox for memory, the
informational inbox, that it grabs new memories.
And when you don't have sleep, that hippocampal
structure, it's almost like it becomes
waterlogged, as it were, and you can't —
Tim Ferriss: Doesn't sound good.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — absorb new information. No.
Well, coming back to inbox analogy, I suppose,
it's almost like the inbox is full and you just
start bouncing those incoming mails, you don't
commit the experience to memory, because what we
discovered is that the hippocampus is shut down.
And so, no wonder you can't imprint that new
information. We also found that if you want to
reverse that trend and say, "How can I increase
my learning capacity?" we did a nap study during
the day and what we found is that it's not just
sleep, but it's a particular bursting electrical
brainwave called a sleep spindle, and the more
of those sleep spindles that you are having, the
greater the restoration of your learning ability.
So the way we did the study, we took a group of
people and we had them try and learn a whole set
of information at midday, and then we brought
them back and then at 6:00 pm we had them
learn an additional new set of information.
And so we could simply compare what's your
learning capacity at time point one versus
time point two. But then, half of the subjects
had a nap in the middle of that six-hour period,
the others did not nap, they remained awake. And
there was a deviation, there was a separation such
that those people who napped, they actually had
a restoration of their learning ability. Those
people that didn't had a deterioration in their
learning ability. And the greater the number of
spindles during the nap, the sleep spindles
that happen during what we call non-rapid
eye movement sleep, the greater the refreshment
and the recuperation of their learning ability.
Tim Ferriss: How long were the naps?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, so the
naps there were 90 minutes in duration.
Now, I wouldn't recommend that for most
people and I'll sort of come back to why, but —
Tim Ferriss: Is that an ultradian rhythm
or is that a bullshit term?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah. I mean,
you were close with suprachiasmatic, and you're
bang on with the ultradian. So ultradian simply
means it's shorter than a day and circadian, when
we describe it, it means approximately or around
a day's length. Ultradian, shorter than a day.
And yes, in human beings, our sleep cycle going
from non-REM to REM, which we repeat, is every
90 minutes. Now, that's in us human beings. It's
different across different species. Our sleep
cycle is actually quite long relative to others.
For example, birds may just have a non-REM to REM
cycle of about two minutes, which is very, very
short. They flip back and forth. Us, 90 minutes.
And so, usually when we do these nap studies,
we give the brain the opportunity to cycle through
both non-REM and REM, so then we give the sleeping
brain the chance to say, "Look, this is the
stage of sleep where you're going to see the
correlation with the benefit that you measure when
you wake that individual up." So we want to give
REM and non-REM an equal opportunity to show their
prowess in transacting a functional benefit for
the brain. That's why we usually do 90 minutes.
But if you're trying to optimize napping,
I should probably do a podcast on this
myself, on the optimal version of napping,
the short and long of it is, nap for about 15
to 20 minutes and no longer, because when you
nap for longer, what happens is that you start
to go down into the deeper stages of non-REM,
and then when you wake up after 30 or 40 minutes,
you're coming out of the deeper stage of sleep
and you have what's called sleep inertia, which
feels like a sleep hangover, and it's even worse
when you wake up than it was before you took the
nap. But if you do 15 or 20 minutes, you don't get
that heavy hit of sleep inertia, but you still get
sleep benefits. Once you get down to about nine,
eight, or seven minutes, we really don't see
brain or body benefits. Getting to 15 to 20,
you get some nice cognitive benefits, but you
lose the downside of the sleep inertia affect.
But I'm digressing, so that's sort of the sleep
before learning, you also need sleep after
learning, however, to then take those new memories
and, as we mentioned before, to sort of fixate
them into the neural architecture of the brain. It
is like hitting the save button, but the problem
is, it's not digital in your Word document, which
happens in milliseconds. The saving of memories in
the brain is an organic process, it requires the
building of new proteins between your synapses, so
it takes hours. But it takes hours not just during
wake, but during sleep. And there, what we found
is that it's during deep non-REM sleep or deep
non-rapid eye movement sleep that the brain will
cement those new memories. It's almost like
that scene in Jurassic Park where the amber
has fixated the fly in perpetuity. And sleep
futureproofs the information within your brain.
And this perhaps comes onto both the mechanism,
but also the idea of time that we discussed or
that we should discuss, perhaps.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, could I pause
before we get to time just to ask
about the kind of neuroanatomical or
plausible mechanisms for ongoing need for sleep
in order to have accurate recall later? Now,
I may be misremembering this, but when
I read your book, one of the studies
that seemed to hop out to me, maybe I was
having a fever dream, so please correct me,
but it was looking at sleep deprivation at
different points after initial acquisition of
knowledge. So you had students who were studying,
and this may have been alcohol-related, as well,
so you'll have to clarify for me, but one
might think sleep before learning, important,
yes, of course. Sleep, say, the night after
learning, important, yes. But as I recall,
it was something like three days later, if you
interrupted the sleep, whether by deprivation
or alcohol, that you subsequently saw lower recall
scores, something like that. Am I inventing this?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, no, your memory is
pinpoint accurate. So your sleep is not, perhaps,
quite as bad as one would fear. You're right. So
we've done these studies and there are perhaps
two studies that speak to your point. One of the
studies, you have people learn some information,
and then you deprive them of sleep the first night
after learning. But then you don't test them,
you give them all of the recovery sleep that they
want on a second night and a third night, and then
you test them. And what we find is that the memory
recollection is still impaired out on day five.
So, in other words, if you don't sleep within
the first 24 hours after learning, you lose the
chance to consolidate those memories. So sleep,
for memory, is an all-or-nothing phenomenon.
And if you're not snoozing that first night,
you're losing, and no amount of recovery sleep,
on the second or the third night, was going to
salvage the process because it seems as though
that there is a selective time window
of opportunity for consolidation and
if you miss it, unfortunately, it's gone.
So in that way, sleep isn't like the bank,
that you can't accumulate that debt and then try
to pay it off at a later point in time. That was
the first study. Then, there was another study
done by Carlyle Smith, a great memory researcher,
we didn't do the study, but I'm so jealous,
because it's such a brilliant study. He was
looking at different forms of sort of creative
learning, which we know is more dependent on
REM sleep. Learning facts, textbook information,
and saving that stuff, that's about deep non-REM
sleep and we can speak about the mechanisms.
When it comes to integrating and associating
the information, as we spoke about, that's more
about REM sleep. So he did a very clever study,
he knew that one of the major consequences of
alcohol's disruption on your sleep is not just
that it sedates you, not just that it fragments
your sleep, but it's very potent at blocking
your dream sleep, and the reason is because of the
aldehydes, the metabolic byproduct, and something
called acetaldehyde is the main reason that
your REM sleep is demolished by way of alcohol.
And he was very interested in this idea, because
we knew at the time that REM sleep, dreaming,
was associated with this type of creative memory.
So he took a group of individuals and he separated
them into about four or five different groups
and everyone learned this information on the
first day, which required them to sort of create
— it was actually very much like learning a novel
language. It was an abstract analogical
language, almost like learning a computer
code that's completely foreign to you and it's
not just about learning the individual pieces,
it's understanding the grammatical rules
of this big picture structure, associative.
So they learned it on day one, and then out
on day seven, they tested those individuals.
So they learned it without any alcohol in
their system, and then they were tested seven
days later without any alcohol in their system.
But here was the clever twist, one group across
those subsequent six nights, they slept normally
with no alcohol. The second group, the first night
after learning that information, they got them,
essentially, just to the point of inebriation,
to about the point of being blood alcohol illegal,
0.08 percent, and it was a body standardized dose
across individuals. So you had one group,
the control group, the second group they
got a little bit tipsy on night one, and then
the subsequent nights they were alcohol free.
Then there was a third group of individuals
who had — they learned on day one, sober,
then they had natural sleep the first night, no
drinking. Then they had natural sleep the second
night and no drinking. And then, on the third
night, that's when they dosed them with alcohol,
and then, again, everyone was tested on day seven.
And what did they find? Firstly, relative to the
group that got a full night of good sleep
every single night across the six nights,
their memory was still there, it was present. But
in the group that had alcohol dosed on the first
night, there was a greater than a 50 percent loss
of their memory out on day seven, because of the
impact of alcohol on night one on REM sleep. But
the frightening part was the night three group.
So the third group, they were very good,
they said, "Okay," let's say it's a student,
"I've been learning on Wednesday and I've
got all of this information, I'm not going
to go out with my friends drinking on Wednesday
night because sleep is important for memory,
and then I'm not going to go out on Thursday night
because I've just learned all this information,
but then, on Friday, surely, my memories are now
safe. I'm going to go out. I'm going to have a
few drinks. Au contraire, because even alcohol on
night three caused almost the same. It was about
a 40 percent deficit in memory. And what that
tells us is not just something about alcohol,
it tells us that the sleeping brain is
still processing and consolidating and
digesting information three days after the act
of learning itself. Yeah, it was a great study,
and you've got a fantastic memory. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That's the one that the blew me away,
and I was like, "Oh, my God."
Dr. Matthew Walker: It's tough,
isn't it? It's like, "Please, come on."
Tim Ferriss: I know. Why does biology
have to steal all the fun? But it raises all
these interesting questions that, again, not to
belabor the point, but having been very involved
through the Saisei Foundation with funding various
scientific initiatives, science costs money.
And there is federal funding and you have
NIH and so on, but some of these studies are
probably unlikely to be done any time soon.
But I wonder what the fragile plasticity range
is for, say, associative/creative work versus
straight declarative, memorize this list of
35 things, right, and if those windows are
different. I would imagine they probably are,
it's hard to say, but it highlights for me,
yes, we know a lot of things, but how many
exciting questions there are that we don't have,
as of yet, really clear answers to.
Dr. Matthew Walker: I think that's a really
interesting point when it comes to therapy because
therapy is not just about targeting any one
individual memory, it's trying to put it together
both in the context of your back autobiography
catalog of knowledge and experience and it's also,
often in therapy, trying to recontextualize it
with new information to dissipate the negative
affect. That is an incredibly complex thing for
a memory system to achieve. In other words,
what you're trying to do is break previous
associations, form new associations, and
change, essentially, the emotional and
the informational weighting of memories and
the weighting of the different connections,
dissipate some, increase others. That's a process
that I suspect does not happen across one night of
sleep, it happens across multiple nights of sleep,
and I think it has implications for therapy too.
Tim Ferriss: Have your therapy
on Monday and not on Thursday if
you're going to drink on the weekends.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Exactly, before you
go out, yeah. I think it's very —
Tim Ferriss: I'm not kidding,
right? It sounds like a flippant comment, but —
Dr. Matthew Walker: No, I don't think it is a
flippant comment. Look, life is to be lived. Have
a drink, of course, I'm not being puritanical, but
if you are, let's say, a student or you've been
learning new information for a new job or you've
been learning a new skill for a new particular
sport and you know when you've been learning and
you know when you probably want to have a night
out, restructure those things to implement them in
the smartest way possible for optimizing outcomes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I will say, fortunately for me,
in college, I have just a strange pseudo-allergic
reaction to most beers, so given that I was dirt
poor, along with most other students, that was the
only thing really on offer, so I didn't drink very
much. I did pull a lot of all-nighters, and what
I would say, and this is not to encourage anyone
to pull all-nighters, but if there's a 20 to
40 percent penalty, but you have not covered 80
percent of the material that might be on a test,
you could still hypothetically net out positive,
right, which is not to say you should do it.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah. No, I think that's
very true, but one of the other interesting
things that we did a study, and we never
actually ended up publishing the data, we wanted
to do some follow-up studies, but it comes on to
this point. I think you're right in that logic
that, if you've not learned 80 to 90 percent,
even though your learning is going to be 20 to 40
percent deficient in its capacity, time on task in
that break-glass-in-case-of-emergency situation is
still going to be in your favor, you could argue,
setting aside, of course, all of the deleterious
consequences that come of that night of sleep.
Not to mention, if you're driving to your exam the
next day, your chances of getting in a fatal car
accident are astronomically high.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, so bad.
Dr. Matthew Walker: But let's just put that aside
for now. Let's think about it from an educational
context, because I wrote an op-ed for when I
was back as faculty at Harvard and I was asked
to write a piece for the Harvard Crimson. We'd
just published some work on sleep and memory,
some of the first in that area, and I wrote
the op-ed and said the frequency of pulling
all-nighters at the end of the semester for
exams is so rife and it is not the student's
fault. The fault is us, the faculty. Why? Because
we end-load the semester with all of these inane,
idiotic exams, and no wonder, what do you think
is going to happen? You're putting students in a
pressure cooker, of course, they're all going to
be pulling all-nighters, and it's counterfactual
to the very idea of higher education.
It's not the student's fault. We are the
people at fault and we need to reorganize and
restructure how we examine individuals. Now,
of course, that was the last time I was ever asked
to write an op-ed for the Crimson. I suppose that
told me everything I needed to know. But
it comes on to my point, which is this:
what's the goal of education? The goal of
education, in my mind, is twofold. The first is
to brainwash you into thinking for yourself. The
second is for you to gain long-term information.
We did a study where we suggested, okay,
you haven't learned any of the information,
and we tested your hypothesis, and sure enough,
yes, time on task returns some degree of a
greater benefit if you pull the all-nighter.
And they were better in terms of the testing
relative to if you chose, obviously, not to
engage in the material at all. At that point,
there's no learning whatsoever. Of course,
you're worse. What was interesting, however,
is that, in the people who had the same amount of
learning opportunity, but then got a full night
of sleep afterwards, relative to the next day,
yes, the people who got sleep were better than
those people who were sleep-deprived, but
then we brought them back four weeks later,
and then we tested them a second time, and
the difference between those two groups
now was magnified almost tenfold.
In other words, the people who had
been sleep-deprived the first night, yes, they
could still test to a degree, they were worse,
but they still got some degree of the answers
right, but the amount of catastrophic forgetting
that happened across those following four
weeks relative to the group that imprinted
those memories and saved them the first night
was far less. There was a lot less forgetting in
the group that had — and I put this in context
simply because I don't want to simply educate
human minds, which is what I do as a job, only for
you to test well the next day, but then, two years
later, you've got none of that information in
your brain. What's the point of higher education
then? It should be long term. And so it's a very
insightful suggestion that you make, and we tried
to test it. I should publish some of that data.
Tim Ferriss: Question on that study,
were the groups randomly assigned, or were the
members of each cohort choosing which cohort
they wanted to belong to?
Dr. Matthew Walker: No,
they were randomly assigned.
Tim Ferriss: I was just wondering
because I was thinking, if somebody chose to be
in the sleep-deprivation group, their self-care
might suck over the subsequent four weeks.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah. Now I would say,
though, the study is partly flawed in
terms of its selection bias because,
ahead of time, we tell them in the consent
form, "Look, you could be in a group that
is going to be sleep-deprived or a group that
you're going to have your sleep well-rested
and full, and so would you like
to continue?" In some ways,
they know that they're rolling the dice,
they could or could not be sleep-deprived,
and so you could argue there's still a selection
bias in that regard, but we don't do selection
assignment. We do random assignment.
Tim Ferriss: Science is hard,
man. It's like people, I shouldn't say people,
that's too broad, but a lot of folks don't
realize just how hard it is, right?
Dr. Matthew Walker: It is, but —
Tim Ferriss: It's really hard.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — it's so rewarding though.
Tim Ferriss: It is. It is.
Dr. Matthew Walker: At the moment when we analyze
the data, and I'm sitting there with a student
or I'm analyzing data, and we finally run the
statistics, at that moment in time, if I'm lucky,
I know something that has never been understood in
the entirety of human civilization, and I cannot
tell you how much of a thrill and a privilege that
is. And so is science hard? It's brutally
hard, but just that alone, the hedonic rush
that you get from de novo knowledge, gosh, it's
never left me, and I don't think it ever will.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah, what a drug.
Dr. Matthew Walker: It's quite the drug.
Get a belt around my arm, the vein is up, and
I will go intravenous with that all day long.
Tim Ferriss: I want to ask you about sleep
spindles because you mentioned that in the context
of napping and how that seems to be a determining
factor or a critical factor in later performance,
cognitive performance. I want to come back
to see if there are any levers you can pull,
even if you wouldn't recommend them for a long
period of time, right? Are there levers you can
pull to increase the frequency or amplitude of
these sleep spindles? And I say that not really
knowing sleep spindles well, but I'm planting
that seed, so I'm going to let that germinate.
But, first, I want to tell you a personal
experience and see how you might speak to
it because I have a pretty good out-of-the-box
memory, I think my hardware and genetics are
reasonably good for it, but I've had a few outlier
experiences that are still, to this day, stand-out
experiences, and one of them was, while I was
studying at a university in China, and we were
responsible, at the advanced levels, for being
able to produce, so not just recognize, but also
actively write many thousands of characters,
and some of these characters have 15,
20 strokes. They're very intricate.
And I had this experience of getting very sick.
I can't remember exactly what caused it, maybe I
never learned what caused it, but I had a fever.
And there was this big exam the next
day, and it was mostly characters,
but in the context of essays. It was
not just memorizing characters and
being familiar with new terminology, some of it,
very abstract. It's not like the cat, it's like
hyperinflation, that kind of stuff. And
I was bedridden because I had a fever,
but I knew this test was coming the
next day, and I had a very high fever.
And the way that my studying proceeded was I would
wake up for 30 minutes and study super intensely,
and then I would feel really sleepy and I would
just fall asleep right on the book on the bed,
and then I would wake up and I would do another
30-minute burst and then fall asleep. And,
when I went into the test the next day, I was
feeling somewhat better, but I'd slept a lot of
the previous day, and I'd studied a lot of the
previous day and it was intended to be, I want
to say, maybe a 90-minute or two-hour exam. And I
finished the exam in something like 25 minutes and
I handed it in and they were like, "What are you
doing?" and I was like, "I think I'm done," and
they're like, "You can't be done," and I was done.
Not only was I done, but I scored 95-plus percent
on the test, and that blew me away and I don't
really have a great way to explain it. And maybe
it was just a freak incident and I'm reading
too far into it, but I've spent a lot of time
around very, very, very smart people, including
people who have very impressive memories, and,
for me personally, in my life, I think I've
done a good job of learning many different
skills and memorizing many different things, but
that particular test stands out as very unusual.
Do you have any thoughts on that?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, I do,
and I think it comes back to the neural mechanisms
of memory consolidation. There are at least two
different mechanisms, non-mutually exclusive, that
promote the cementing of that new information,
but also the freeing up of your short-term
memory capacity. And what we've discovered,
we and others have done this work, the first
method is a file transfer mechanism that, when you
go into deep non-REM sleep, which, by the way, is
dialed up by way of infection, when you get sick,
you have an increase in sleep drive, particularly
for deep non-REM sleep. We know why. There are a
number of immune factors, inflammatory factors,
that call up to play this thing called deep sleep.
Those immune factors are things like cytokines
and they are very sleep-inducing. That's why
you typically want to curl up and get into bed.
That's why you typically sleep more when you are
sick because the human organism understands that
the very best health insurance policy that it has,
the very best Swiss Army knife of health,
is this tool called sleep, and it brings
all of the armament of sleep to the call.
Part of the reason you were sleeping so much
is because you were undergoing the infection.
You had a supercharged amount of deep sleep,
it turns out. What happens, the first mechanism
of deep sleep, is that during — and it's not
just the sleep spindles, and it's not just the
big, powerful, slow waves of deep non-REM sleep,
it's the combination of those two that we've
discovered. We've published some work where,
as long as you get this perfect timing between a
slow wave and then a sleep spindle, it's almost
like making sure that the drummer is directly on
the beat in this rhythmic capacity, so you have a
slow wave and then you have a sleep spindle riding
on top of it, this electrical burst of activity.
The slow waves, they go up and down maybe once or
twice a second. The sleep spindles, they burst at
about 14 or 15 times per second, 14 or 15 hertz.
And it's the timing, the combined quality of
these two deep sleep brainwaves, that will shift
memories from a short-term, vulnerable reservoir,
the hippocampus, to a more permanent long-term
storage site within the brain and protecting
them. And that long-term storage site is the
cortex that sits on top of your brain. I don't
want to do computer-brain analogies, but I suppose
the idea would be your hippocampus is a little bit
like a USB stick, that it's very good at running
around during the day and grabbing individual
files from different locations, but it has a
limited storage capacity. But then, at night,
you shift those memories from that short-term
reservoir of the hippocampus to the hard drive,
the cortex, which gives you two benefits.
The first is that that which you learned
before sleep is now shifted over and
protected and safe in the new location,
but the second benefit is that, because you've
cleared out the USB stick of the hippocampus,
when you wake up, you've got a refreshed learning
ability and so you can start acquiring new files
all over again. It's a symbiotic relationship
that we've discovered. And I think that's one
of the explanations for why you were able to just
rip through the material, do it in a short burst.
By the way, we know that that's optimal for
learning. It's called massed versus spaced
practice. If you try to learn in one long bout,
not great. If you chunk it up into different
segments, your learning is much better. You
still spend the same two hours of learning,
but, if you spread it across four hours than two
hours straight, much better. But sleep is a part
of that. That's the first of the two mechanisms.
Tim Ferriss: That's fascinating. I have a number
of follow-up questions. The first is
just on the — there are many different
iterations of spaced repetition, but
in these short-burst study sessions is,
how do you explain the benefit of that versus
longer duration? One thing that leaps to mind
for me, which may or may not be true based on
your read of the literature, but is that you have
this primacy and recency effect in any given study
session, but you can, in a sense, keep the — what
that would mean is the first thing you
study and the last thing you study,
you're generally going to recall, say in a word
list, better than things in the middle. Okay.
Now, if that's true in a four-hour session,
you have, let's just say, this almost Golden
Gate Bridge, high-tension wire type of dip in
the middle, but, if you have shorter sessions,
the actual drop of that high tension wire is
going to be less, so your average retention
over each individual session will be higher.
And maybe that's just me spouting nonsense,
but that's what jumps to mind. Does that mesh?
Dr. Matthew Walker: No, it does mesh very well,
which is that you're getting the primacy and
the recency. It's like this bow shape where
the information in the middle of the list, you
don't remember very well, but the stuff at the
front and the back end of it, you do remember
well. Well, if you do only one learning session,
you only get two stanchions, either end
of the bridge of primacy and recency, but,
if you split it up into six chunks, then you're
getting six hits of primacy and recency, which
gives you a greater benefit. That's one of them.
The other we think actually relates to attention,
which is that your ability to focus and attend
and have a spotlight of attentional focus, you
need attention to imprint information, at least
consciously, there is non-conscious learning too,
and when you are constantly time on task,
that spotlight of attention starts to
fade and your ability to focus on what you
should learn decreases and therefore what
you learn decreases. It's not really related
to the fact of your memory fatiguing itself,
but I think there's evidence for that too.
One of the things that I've always been
fascinated by, and I want to do the study,
but it's one of those bucket-list studies,
I don't think it's quite as simple as that. I, at
least, have found in my own personal experience,
and heard from others, that I could be learning
information about organic chemistry for an hour,
and I just know that I'm just starting to fade.
My learning is just getting miserable. It's just
diminishing returns at this point. But then, if I
close the book and I start trying to learn French,
I actually think my learning capacity
is renewed and refreshed. And so I think
there is something about the context
of the information that the familiarity
versus the novelty can also reinstantiate your
learning ability. Does that make some sense?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, totally makes sense.
Dr. Matthew Walker: I think this idea of
fatigue, we don't really understand it.
Tim Ferriss: No. Yeah. There seem to be these
compartmentalized capabilities. It's very —
Dr. Matthew Walker: Isn't that —
Tim Ferriss: It's wild. It's so wild. I will say
for folks, also, I use the example of word lists,
but having attempted, somewhat successfully
in most cases, to acquire different
skills, motor skills, sports, et cetera,
different capabilities, it could even be
something like poker, which is a combination
of all sorts of things, that the same type
of short duration sessions and breaks help. It's
not limited to pure, what we might consider book
learning, at least in my experience. Let me ask
two questions and I'll let you pick the first one.
I'd love to hear you comment on both though.
The first is, if you wanted to put your sleep
spindles on hyperdrive for a short period
of time, who knows, final exam, right,
I expect the slow wheels of institutionalized
academia will probably not completely reformat the
end-of-semester testing default that they have had
for so long, so if someone had infinite resources
and they wanted to put their sleep spindles on
hyperdrive, how might they do that? The other one
is you mentioned a term earlier with respect to
lucid dreaming. That was charlatan science. It was
considered charlatan science for a long time until
it wasn't. And I would be super curious to know if
there's anything that is currently, and this might
make you uncomfortable, but I'll do it if there's
anything that is currently considered along the
lines of charlatan science that you think might
similarly bear out as lucid dreaming did?
Dr. Matthew Walker: In terms of the sleep
spindles, and I wouldn't probably just focus
on the sleep spindles, I would focus on the
combination of deep slope brainwaves and —
Tim Ferriss: The synchronization.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — yeah, the synchronization
of this. What we call it is phase amplitude
coupling is the technical term, which is —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that makes sense.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — the phase of the
wave and the coupling of the peak of that.
Tim Ferriss: Two people jumping
on a trampoline at the same time.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Exactly, yeah, and you
want those to just go just in this lovely
rhythmic sync. We've been developing some brain
stimulation technology to see if we can do this.
We can certainly boost your deep sleep brainwaves
with brain stimulation. We can also improve your
sleep spindles. And, here, what we're doing is
we're applying electricity through the brain
where you don't feel it it's so small, it's
a small voltage, but we can stimulate the
slow frequency brainwave and we can act like a
choir to that flagging lead vocalist and boost
those slow waves, but we can also stimulate at
the frequency of the sleep spindles, which is
a much faster frequency, somewhere between
12 to 15 hertz, 12 to 15 cycles per second,
and we can also induce those sleep spindles.
By the way, motor learning is another good
example. We did some studies, gosh, 10 years
ago now at least where we found that motor
skill learning was also dependent on lighter
stages of non-REM sleep, but, once again,
on sleep spindles. And a recent group, this
wasn't us, although we're doing these studies too,
they applied stimulation at the sleep spindle
frequency range and they were able to improve
aspects of motor skill learning as well, which
is wild when you think about airline pilots,
musicians, and professional athletes. Can you
actually adopt and learn some of these new
skills and then supercharge them overnight with
electrical brain stimulation? Is that going to be,
in 10 years time, a banned electro-ceutical
rather than a banned pharmaceutical in sports?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, or will it be a required
electro-ceutical for, say, airline pilots and what
ethical questions does that raise, right?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Exactly, and what are
we trying to do, and always got to think
about free lunches and if you ever get one.
I would say that that's probably one of the
areas. I would also say that the sleeping brain
often takes care of itself. What we've learned
is that, when you have people do intensive
learning sessions and you measure their sleep that
following night relative to when they've not been
doing intensive learning sessions, lo and behold,
the brain after the intensive learning session,
artificially for that night — it's not
artificially. Adaptively for that night,
increases the amount of spindles that it gets.
Your brain actually knows what it needs and it
self-medicates with greater numbers of spindles.
Tim Ferriss: How cool.
Dr. Matthew Walker: So we may almost not
need to worry about that. Yeah, it's wild,
isn't it? When we made that discovery.
Tim Ferriss: What an amazing piece of
wetware we carry between our ears. What a thing.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah. The other aspect of
memory that you could optimize,
and people have been doing this,
and I don't think it's mainstream yet, comes back
to the second mechanism of why sleep is good for
memory. It's not just about shifting memories from
short term to long term. It's about memory replay.
And this study, or this story, emerged back in the
1990s when a scientist called Bruce McNaughton at
the University of Arizona, he was measuring
the memory cell activity in rats as they were
running around a maze and he was trying to learn
how the hippocampus codes a maze and, basically,
how it builds a memory circuit of the maze. And he
was recording individual cells in the hippocampus,
and he wasn't doing this, but you can just
think of this as each cell has a tone to it and,
as the rat would run around the maze, what
he would hear is the signature of learning
that would sound a little bit like (singing).
As the rat was running around the maze, he was
listening to the brain imprinting these memories.
The brilliant part of his study was that he didn't
stop recording when the session ended. He kept
recording from that memory center as those rats
went into sleep and went into deep non-REM sleep.
And, when they went into deep non REM sleep,
he kept listening. And, when you eavesdrop on the
sleeping brain, not only was the memory replayed,
but it wasn't replayed at waking speed. It
was replayed almost 10 times faster. Instead,
what he was hearing, instead of (singing),
he was hearing — as if these rats were just
replaying the memory at high frequency speed
as if they're etching the memory into the
glass surface of the brain and scoring
the memory trace even more powerfully.
We know that memory replay is
a critical component of that.
Then studies — it probably restarted back with
some French scientists in the early 2000s,
and then there was a big paper in Nature by
a German group, and they tried to hijack the
system of memory replay, and it was brilliant. It
was so clever. And now Ken Paller at Northwestern
has been doing some of these studies. Here's
what they did. They had people learn information,
but they associated that information with
somatosensory stimuli. And what I mean by
that is you're learning a list of words and then,
during that list of words, I am infusing a rose
perfume up your nose with a mask, and what you're
doing, the brain is bonding the scent, the odor,
of the rose with the learned information, so
now you've got a bonded memory with the odor.
Then what they would do is they would
let those individuals fall asleep
and, during deep non-REM sleep, when we
believe the memories are being replayed,
they started to reperfuse that rose odor up
their nose. And, as a consequence, the next day,
there was about a 40 to 50 percent improvement
in their memory because they had brute-forced
the reactivation of the memory. It's almost as
though they decided to take that memory and give
it VIP access to the memory replay during non-REM
sleep, and you start to cherry-pick information.
And then Ken Paller and others, they started to
look at this and they did it even more cleverly.
I think the way the game over here in America
is actually called Memory, where it's a set of
cards all out on the table, and each card has its
own pair. You turn one card over and it's a house
and you turn another card over, and somewhere in
the rest of the deck there is another house that's
the match. And then there is one teakettle and
then there is one fire engine. And so they would
do all of these things. But they did this on the
computer, and each time they were learning this
associative spatial layout of information.
When they would turn over the teakettle,
they would hear a teakettle sound, and,
when they'd turn over the fire engine,
they would hear a fire engine sound. Once again,
they were bonding a sound, a congruent semantic
sound, with that particular information
visually. And then they let them sleep.
And, as they went into deep non-REM sleep,
they would replay those sounds at what we call
a sub-awakening threshold, where it was loud
enough to get into the brain, but not loud —
Tim Ferriss: Critical detail for people asleep.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, please, please,
please don't do that. And what they were able
to do is, essentially, an even more selective
process of cherry-picking. Now, whatever I want to
serve up to the menu of this thing called sleep at
night in terms of the different dishes of memory,
I get to choose. I can say, "No, no, no, I don't
want that information. I want this particular
information tonight and I'm going to develop
this auditory playlist." And so the question then
becomes can you start using that method? Is the
cheap version of that that I'm going to study
organic chemistry and I'm going to blaze up some
green tea incense, which I personally really
like, and then, before I go to bed at night,
am I going to put back on the green tea incense
and start trying to stuff that back up my nose
and either improve my memory or burn my house
down and be a scientist no more and chargrill
the rest of my body, because it's a desperate
fire safety hazard and you'd never want to do it?
But this is the idea, that there's something
that we're starting to understand about the
sleeping brain that not just is understanding,
but it gives us the ability to take control. And,
at that point, that becomes scary because should
we be taking control of a process that maybe is
not really our purview to be in control of?
Tim Ferriss: Sounds like the story of
humankind in a nutshell right there.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, I know. Yeah, you
can almost see visions of the atomic bomb. By
the way, I would say that, it's a bit extreme,
Matthew, but what happens during REM sleep is
really quite different. It's during deep non-REM
sleep that those memories are replayed at, as I
said, about 10 times faster. But, when you go into
dream sleep, and this is work done by Matt Wilson,
not me, Matt Walker, Matt Wilson at MIT. He found
that the rat brain does replay memories during
REM sleep, but it doesn't replay them faster and
it doesn't even replay them at waking speed.
It replays them at about 0.5 times the speed.
It's like listening to this podcast and, all
of a sudden, you hit that button that says —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, 0.5x.
Dr. Matthew Walker: — go slow and everyone
slows down. And I think this has relationships
to the component of time and our time perception,
which is totally freaky, by the way. Time, and
I've written about this and have a few theories
and we're really interested about how to do
this — by the way, I haven't forgotten about
your question, as to what is charlatan
science, and I will come back to that,
because I've vaguely still holding onto my memory
despite being in the foothills of middle age.
The time perception is interesting. When you
and I, let's say we go on a long-haul flight,
and you're lucky enough to actually fall asleep on
the flight, and it's dark on the flight. When you
wake up, what is one of the first things that
you do? One of the first things that you do,
is you check your watch, you check your phone,
because you're trying to look to the time. Because
when you sleep, you lose all conscious perception
of time. You've got no idea. And that's the reason
that you check, "How long have I been asleep?"
Well, why don't you know? I don't know,
because I don't track sleep time when
I'm sleeping. However, when you dream,
something different happens. And maybe you've had
this experience. I certainly have, and many people
have. Your alarm goes off, and you have a snooze
button, and the snooze button is for five minutes.
So the alarm wakes you up, and you hit the snooze
button. And you were dreaming, and you go back to
sleep and you go back to dreaming. Maybe it's
the same dream, maybe it's a different dream.
And then the alarm goes off again, and it's
been five minutes in the waking world. But you,
personally, you think, "That wasn't five minutes.
I felt like I was dreaming for 20 minutes,
30 minutes, 40 minutes." As if time is different
in the dreamscape. And what I've described this as
is time dilation. That it's during dream
sleep, that we almost stretch time out.
What would be the neurobiological basis of that?
Well, I think it could be some of this rat work
that suggests that perhaps during dream sleep,
the brain slows down the recapitulation of time.
And you can have all sorts of fun with this idea.
Christopher Nolan was wise enough to consult some
sleep researchers, and come up with this idea in
Inception, where we'd have different dream levels,
where in the first level, five minutes in the
waking world is now 50 minutes at the first
level of the dream. And you go down the next
level, and now five minutes is now five hours,
and then the next level it's five years,
and the next level it's 50 years. And you're
constantly doing this sort of time dilation, as
it were. It comes up with some fascinating ideas,
but science is just getting to that
position now, where we can understand
time during sleep. Because it is strange.
It's a very strange thing, time, with sleep.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I mean, if you sit with that
for a minute, I mean that is one of the strangest
experiences that is very hard to fit into our sort
of paradigms of thinking about things right now,
right? I mean, the idea that you could have more
than five minutes, you could have 40 minutes of
experience, subjective experience, in five
minutes of waking, Earth time. No matter if we
take the fidelity of the firsthand experience to
be high, in so much as it being a real experience,
it raises a lot of very, very
hard-to-answer questions.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, it's fascinating too.
And right now, I do have a neural hypothesis for
this, and there's a part of the brain called the
insular cortex, that sort of is in the left and
the right side, but it's buried deep inside. And
it serves many different functions, but one of its
functions is the mapping of your bodily state,
of your emotions, and the updating it, from one
moment to the next, to the next. So the insular
cortex is consistently mapping the physiological
state of your body, from one moment, to the
next, to the next. The reason I bring that up is
because the physiological emotional state of your
body contributes to time. How does it do that?
I think you and I, and everyone listening,
has also had that experience, where they said,
"I just had this emotional experience, and all
of a sudden time slowed down." I remember when I
was an avid cyclist, and I've been knocked off my
bike a few times. And I remember one time, I was
going through, and a car came out of a junction,
and I could just see it. And it hit me, and I went
through the windscreen of the car and came out.
And that moment of time, which was, obviously,
a pretty traumatic, pretty emotional event,
when you get knocked off your bike through a
car windscreen. Time just slowed down. The emotion
was so intense, that all of a sudden it was like
when you see on a video camera, you go from a
standard frame rate, and all of a sudden — and
you can now do it on your iPhone, you can slow
it down, and you can get really high resolution,
slow temp, or slow motion activity.
It was like that, because the insular
cortex was starting to map with much higher frame
rates, and therefore time slowed down. I realized
I was going to be hit, and I realized I'm clipped
into my pedals on the bike. I'm going to clip out,
because I don't want to go under the car, where my
bike is going. I'd much prefer to go over the car,
onto the windscreen, and off. So I remembered —
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Dr. Matthew Walker: And that happened, obviously,
within milliseconds, but I remember clipping out,
thinking all of this within time.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. Yeah.
Dr. Matthew Walker: And I think what's happening
is that the insular cortex has some interesting
changes. We see it changing in its activity
during dream sleep. My prediction is that
if I start to map your perception of time
in dream sleep, I think it's going to be
predicted by changes in activity within this
part of the brain, called the insular cortex,
which is constantly mapping the affective visceral
state of your experience consciously. So I've got
a neural theory. It's hand waving, though.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, the time machine.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Time machine.
Tim Ferriss: So if I try to then just
restate that, so I ensure that I'm understanding
it correctly. Is it your insular cortex? No.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yes. Insular cortex. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Insular cortex has the ability to
effectively increase your frame rate
in certain circumstances, which is
ostensibly resource-intensive, and there's a
cognitive load, therefore it doesn't do it all
the time. Right? Because I mean, perception
of reality, in a sense, is a shorthand,
a lot of the times, of sorts. I mean, it seems
that way at least, otherwise we would just be
on psychedelics all the time, experientially,
and that would be just unmanageable. I suppose
where I wanted to — that's just a restatement. Is
that a fair lay restatement of what you just said?
Dr. Matthew Walker: It's an accurate statement
in the sense that the insular cortex does do
that mapping of time, but it doesn't seem
to do it all of the time, and some of it
probably non-consciously. But they have done
studies, where let's say that you ask people
to, say, count time, count two minutes of time.
And they'll just sit there, and they'll just try
and sense time, quantify time. The accuracy
from one individual to the next, in terms of
mapping that subjective sense of two minutes,
is predicted by the insular activity itself.
The greater the insular activity, the greater
your precision of mapped timing. So it really
does seem to be one of the seats of mapped time.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It makes me wonder if this is
one of the unmeasured performance-enhancing
variables in, for instance, batters in major
league baseball, who claim to be able to
see the stitching on the baseball as it
travels towards them as a fastball. How much of
that is innate versus trained? If it's innate,
it would be very interesting if that were a
deciding factor in performance in certain sports.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Let's hop to the
charlatan science. No, hold on one second. So the
question is not so much what is charlatan science,
because I think that's somewhat evident in the
term itself. I think most people kind of grok
what that means. The question is: what is
currently being dismissed, or cast aside,
much as lucid dreaming was for a long time, that
may in fact become a credible area of inquiry
in the foreseeable future?
Dr. Matthew Walker: To me,
and this is probably just because we've been
talking about dreaming for so long, I do have
a theory of dreaming that is currently not very
well supported. Most science right now suggests,
just as I did when it comes to dreaming,
that we are amnesic, that we forget most,
if not all, of our dreaming life, that it's just
not imprinted into our brains. I think that there
could be a day and a time in the future where we
realize we have been desperately wrong about this,
and that our dreaming lives are influencing our
waking lives in a far more powerful way than we
ever thought. I was going to say dreamed, than
we ever thought possible. And here's the reason.
We know that there is such a thing as
non-conscious memory, or implicit memory, and
I think people have conflated an issue with memory
that is about accessibility versus availability.
And what I mean by that is you can learn some
information, and it can be available, it can be
there in your brain, that memory is present, but
you, for whatever reason, lose the IP address to
the memory, so it is not accessible. And right
now, we have conflated accessibility of dreams,
with availability of dreams, such that we say,
"Well, you can't remember most of your dreams,
so we assume that that memory is not available,
that that memory is not present in your brain." I
don't believe that's true. I think that memory
could be present, available, but it's simply
not accessible. And the evidence I have for
this, and it's happened to me multiple times,
I'll wake up in the morning and I know for
a fact I was dreaming. And the harder I try,
I just can't remember it, and it just seems
to evaporate, as if the memory is gone.
And the availability of the memory, its
presence in my brain, we all assume in science,
is no longer there. That memory has evaporated.
But then, two or three days later, I could be in
the shower washing my hair. I look at the shampoo
bottle, and there's something about the label that
triggers the instant recollection of that dream
from three days ago, and it all comes flooding
back. In other words, it wasn't a problem of
availability of the dream, it was a problem
of accessibility of the dream memory. The memory
is there, it's just that I don't have conscious
access to it. Now, if that is true, and if I can
prove that, and I've got some ideas. I mean I've
always got way too many experiments than I can
do, but if I can prove that that's true, what that
could unleash is the maybe scary fact that most
of our dreams, firstly, are residing within us,
and vast amounts of our dreaming life are
non-consciously implicitly unaware to us,
influencing our everyday choices
and our behaviors. That, right now,
sounds a lot like charlatan science. That sounds
like hooey to me, that sounds like total BS.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, and strong
words. Strong words, Matt Walker.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Matt Walker used to do
some fairly hard-nosed, good neuroscience data,
and then towards the end of his career, he kind of
lost it. He was going on podcasts, and he started
dreaming of all these crazy theories, and that was
the end of him. Next we know, he is selling books
door-to-door in some odd country. But I think
that, to me, that could be a wild and plausible,
currently charlatan nonsensical idea. But if
we can prove it, and I think it's a testable
hypothesis, that's why I entertain it, because
I'm a scientist and it has to be a testable
hypothesis. What does that mean for us as a
species, in terms of what dreams do and influence,
to us as a species, and us as a society?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, and it's also, if you
can't get the funding for the study, you might be
able to sell it to Hollywood. I'm just imagining
a film premise, where you have something like
Waking Matt and Dreaming Matt. And those are
certainly one and the same in some respects, but
perhaps in the same way that you can consciously
attempt to recall experiences, data, things
you've memorized, from your waking life,
perhaps through lucidity, you can query
your dream memory, and be more active as
a participant in that mindscape.
Dr. Matthew Walker: And
sculpting that experiential —
Tim Ferriss: I mean, how amazing would
it be if, and I'm getting way out there now, but
if in the same way that you could try to recall,
perhaps with the help of someone like a family
member, what your fifth birthday was like,
or what happened when you graduated from
elementary school, and perhaps you could
have a similar attempt, perhaps successful,
at sort of aided inquiry to identify what
your dreams were like when you were three,
four, five, eight, 11. It opens up all sorts
of narrative possibilities, if not scientific.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Let's write the screenplay.
I'm represented by WME. I don't know if
you're with the same agency, but we should
definitely — let's do the joint screenplay,
and let's sell it for probably about $20.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It's like, "Here's a
great idea, and it'll cost just a mere $20 to
$100,000,000 to try to do a test reel. Good luck.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, I'll email Christopher
Nolan, see what he wants to do.
Tim Ferriss: Well, yeah. If you
can email Christopher Nolan, I'd
love to have him on the podcast too,
but that's a whole separate conversation.
So if we're looking at a few different things
here, I mean we've covered a lot of ground.
I would like to chat for a second about my
fever-induced hypermnesia, my experience with that
Chinese test. And I was listening to you describe
the cytokines, and inflammatory markers, and so
on, which would be associated with that fever.
And it raised the question for me of how you
might simulate that without going out and eating
rotten beef, or whatever gave me food poisoning,
because I wouldn't recommend that.
And then I started to think about
exercise, and its relationship to, or how it might
affect, sleep and memory. And certainly, you have
a whole cascade of things that can happen
with different types of exercise, including
brain drive, neurotrophic factor, into all
these various things. But I was wondering,
if you go through intense exercise, let's just
say intense resistance exercise, you are going to
trigger, I would think, many of the same type of
inflammatory responses and compensatory mechanisms
that you might when you are experiencing an
infection, in a sense. And they're not identical,
I'm not saying that, but where I'm going is, I'm
wondering if there's a role for intense exercise,
that is pro-inflammatory in the
short-term, for enhancing memory.
Dr. Matthew Walker: I think there is, and it's
funny you should mention that. Literally this
week, on my podcast, I released the first of a
three-part series, all about sleep and exercise.
And it's exactly what you predict, that exercise
is hugely beneficial for sleep. The principle
stage of sleep that it seems to induce is an
increase in the amount of deep non-REM sleep,
and particularly the power of those powerful, big,
slow brainwaves. One of the interesting things is,
though, that there is no free lunch, that when
you exercise intensively, if you look across the
studies, yes, you increase the amount of deep
sleep, but it does seem to come at the cost
of REM sleep. That you will have a reliable and
statistical drop in the amount of REM sleep. Now,
I don't think that's anything to be concerned
about if you are exercising. I think it's simply
that, once again, mother nature knows what
the menu of sleep stage options should be,
and prescribes the right one for whatever
conditions you've been doing that day. Whether
it's physical exercise, whether it's learning
intensively material, that is figured out for you.
But you are absolutely right; exercise will induce
that. Part of that is because of the low-grade
inflammation, that it's a pro-inflammatory state
by way of exercise. I think there are other
factors too, that probably help with that. Some of
them may be related to temperature, some of them
may be related to the degree of parasympathetic
down shoot that you get after exercise. So you
get very sympathetic and stressed, in terms
of the nervous system, of course. But then
you typically have this drop that comes down,
and you dip below your typical level. That's
what you see in heart rate. You see it in blood
pressure. That's one of the benefits of exercise.
So I think this nice down shoot, shifting from
the fight or flight, down to the parasympathetic,
in part, is one of the reasons why you
get better sleep by way of exercise.
It benefits across all ages, by the way. It's
not just that young people benefit from exercise,
all people do as well. You can look at
different forms of exercise. And right now,
I don't think there's enough data. There's some
data that aerobic versus resistance training
may lead to somewhat greater benefits on sleep, at
least on deep non-REM sleep, and the consistency —
Tim Ferriss: You're saying on the aerobic side?
Dr. Matthew Walker: So aerobic seems to,
potentially, outdo if you put them head-to-head
in a sort of Coke-Pepsi challenge. It seems to
be that aerobic wins out, somewhat, relative to
the, sorry. So yeah, so the aerobic, so basically
doing cardio seems to produce a greater benefit
relative to resistance training. In other words,
lifting weights. But lifting weights is still
better than doing nothing at all. So don't feel
worried about the fact that, "Oh, my goodness, I'm
principally someone who just goes into the gym and
lifts weights. I'm not going to get the sleep
benefit you will, relative to being sedentary."
That's definitely the worst situation. But
aerobic seems to, and of course it's not,
we call it aerobic exercise, but most of the time
it's anaerobic. It's where you go without oxygen.
That's where all of the good stuff can happen
to, although kind of Zone 2 as well, Peter.
Tim Ferriss: Well, hold on a second. So let's talk
about that for a second. So if we're talking about
anaerobic, does that mean that you're talking
about cardio, in quotation marks, that is above
your lactate threshold, or otherwise sort of
pushing the boundaries of your aerobic capacity,
as opposed to lower intensity, steady state
aerobics? Because the devil's in the details
with this stuff, right?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And that's true for resistance
training, because there's such a spectrum of
different types of resistance training. And I'll
just say as a quick side note for folks, do both.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: You really don't want to have
sarcopenia, and lose muscle mass year-on-year,
as you get older. That is just a recipe for
disaster. So do your weight training or resistance
training. But when you say anaerobic in this case,
what type of protocol are we talking about?
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, so people
have looked at HIIT routines, H-I-I-T.
Tim Ferriss: High-Intensity Interval Training.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Interval training, and they've
also looked at steady-state cardio. Right now,
I don't think we have enough data to separate
between those two. Simply that both of those will
provide a nice sleep benefit, and a boost both
in the — it's not just that it boosts the amount
of deep sleep, it also boosts the continuity
of your sleep, meaning that you're going to
wake up fewer times throughout the night, and
you'll have a nice longer consolidated bout of
total sleep as a consequence. That's one of the
other benefits of exercise on sleep. But again,
resistance training also provides those benefits,
too. They're just not quite as voluminous.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Dr. Matthew Walker: But to your question,
no one has done the systematic study, where you
try to — I mean, it's only now being worked out
in the field of exercise itself, which is
really understanding when you put all of
these different flavors of HIIT, versus Zone 2.
Exactly, what are the nuanced neurobiological
and biophysical changes within the body and
the brain regarding sleep? We've got no idea.
There are studies that have done these different
flavors, but they've never done a randomized
controlled trial, where you assign people to
each one of these two in the same protocol,
and then ask basically, Coke, Pepsi, Dr. Pepper,
Sprite — whatever you want to line up, challenge,
and put them all head-to-head, to see which
one wins out. We don't know right now.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's really
hard, from what I can tell, to
implement studies in exercise science, in a
really clean, precise way. And I don't want to
name names, but I've, at many points, volunteered
to be a subject in experiments all over the place,
and in some very fancy places. I remember being
in one study, and it entailed circuit training.
And so you'd go to different stations, and
you had to do bench press, pull-up, et cetera.
There were a number of other subjects in this
room, and we're rotating around these stations.
And I would see one person doing bench press, very
controlled, in a slower cadence, like four seconds
down, two seconds up, and then the next two people
would be bouncing the bar off their chest using
momentum. And I just thought to myself, "The time
under tension, and the loading here, is apples
and oranges." You're not actually getting a clean
signal, because it's not standardized well enough.
So that's certainly a challenge, I
think, with a lot of these studies.
Let me ask you, though, I'm going to do a hard
left turn, just because you've inspired me,
and I actually want to try to get to the gym
now. But let's talk about urination. So I love
drinking beverages. I'm very well hydrated, and
there's a lot of upside to that. But one of the
downsides is I almost always get up and pee
in the middle of the night. That is not a new
thing. I mean, I'm sure that the plumbing starts
to wane in its strength over time, unfortunately.
Dr. Matthew Walker: It does, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But this has been pretty
consistent for me. I drink a lot of liquids. So
the question is, and I'll say a few more things,
but the question is what are some approaches for
minimizing this as an issue, as a problem? Because
it does interrupt that continuity of sleep.
And I see a market difference in my feelings
of restfulness, on subsequent mornings when
I do or do not get up to go to the bathroom.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So one is drink
less. Okay, fine. I seem to be very bad
at following that advice. Another is, hey,
take something like a desmopressin, which is an
anti-diuretic hormone, that which no one should
do without medical supervision.
Dr. Matthew Walker: No.
Tim Ferriss: I tested that. The problem is, I
ended up experiencing orthostatic hypertension,
where I would stand up and get really dizzy.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Dizzy, and then,
yeah, potentially pass out. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'd get really dizzy. And I thought,
"Wow, that's dangerous. I don't want to screw
around with it." Are there any other techniques,
or thoughts that you have, on this particular
issue? Because I know a lot of men, in particular,
seem to contend with it as they get older.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, I've definitely
experienced this as I'm getting older. I used to
sleep throughout the night. Now I probably get up,
on average, at least once every second
night, to go to the restroom. We don't
have a particularly good approach to
this, in terms of medications. There
are a few medications out there, to try to
decrease the likelihood and the frequency
of those. And I think those medications are more
about trying to increase the expulsion of urine,
such that before bed, you expel more of that
fluid, and so less is left as you are casting
off into sleep to trigger the awakening.
But there's nothing that I know that helps
suppress that reflex and that desire during
sleep. And it's really, then, at that point,
unfortunately, down to, "How do I taper off
my fluid intake throughout the late afternoon,
in the early evening, and is it worth it
to me to get that continuity of sleep?"
Is it that I don't stop drinking the number of
drinks that I have, but starting at 5:00 p.m. or
4:00 p.m., I actually will just have half the size
of the drink that I normally would. So I don't
fool my brain into thinking, "You are in a famine
of fluid." I still have the same number of drinks,
so my habit is still satisfied with having
three, or four, whatever drinks I'm having,
but the volume is halved and therefore
the psychology is still easier to adopt,
but the impact is reduced by 50 percent.
That's one of the ways that you could try to,
or at least I've tried to, get around the effect.
And when people speak to me, I advise them that
that's what one method that you can try to
fool your brain. Don't feel as though you are
stopping yourself from doing what you normally
like to do, but you still get half of the fluid
intake. Other than that, it's very challenging.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. All right. Well, I'll try
the Dr. Walker half-glass trick tonight, and
see how that goes. I'll report back. Matt,
this has been so much fun. We've covered a lot
of ground. Is there anything that you would like
to mention? Anything you'd like to point people
to? Certainly, I think we could refresh where
people can find you online, just so they can
track you down and see what you're up to. So
please feel free to add your closing comments.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah, people can find me.
I'm on Twitter, @sleepdiplomat. I'm on Instagram,
@drmattwalker, that's D-R-M-A-T-T-W-A-L-K-E-R.
And I also have a podcast. If you're not sick and
tired of my voice. And it's creatively called
The Matt Walker Podcast, which can be found
on all platforms. And that's probably about it.
Tim Ferriss: All right. Well, thank you for taking
the time, and I always enjoy our conversation —
Dr. Matthew Walker: Just being a repeat offender,
second repeat offender on the podcast, for
all of the sins that I've offered, in terms
of sleep advice. So thank you for having me.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I'm all about repeat offenders.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Right.
Tim Ferriss: And of course, thank you for putting
on the gloves. To everybody listening, we will
have links to everything that we discussed in the
show notes, as per usual, at tim.blog/podcast. And
until next time, try those half glasses of water
out, and see how that works. Let me know if —
Dr. Matthew Walker: A little bit of sex
in between, as well, and maybe —
Tim Ferriss: A little bit of sex.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, a little bit
of sex sprinkled here and there. And if you don't
have a fantastic partner, then maybe your right or
left hand will do the trick for that 47 percent.
Dr. Matthew Walker: Half glass full in left hand,
keep your right hand free,
and you're good to go for sleep.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Be safe out there,
folks. And as mentioned, till
next time. Thanks for tuning in.